on
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat l'émission qui vous
fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée je vous propose ce matin de
suivre une table ronde sur la relance de
l'économie comment relancer la
consommation l'investissement alors que
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
à annoncer une récession de 11% en
france en 2020
les sénateurs ont interrogé sur ce sujet
des économistes et des chefs
d'entreprise je vous laisse écouter
cette table ronde
bonjour à tous d'abord à nous inviter à
vous mes chers collègues à l'ensemble
des journalistes qui nous suit ce matin
je vais commencer par exemple nous
poursuivons ici notre cycle de tables
rondes de grands témoins deux capitaines
d'industrie d'experts d'économistes qui
nous permettent de prendre un peu de
recul par rapport à l'actualité
immédiate dans laquelle sommes jetés les
uns et les autres
dès la mi mars pour réfléchir aux
orientations dans notre pays et a besoin
en matière économique les échanges
aujourd'hui sont consacrées aux moyens
de relancer la consommation et
l'investissement en france
je très heureuse que notre commission
des affaires économiques accueille pour
l'occasion michel edouard leclerc pdg du
groupe leclerc monsieur patrick martin
président délégué du medef
xavier ragot président de cae et madame
agnès verdier-molinié directrice haut et
du très médiatique et très connu il fera
institut des frappes
madame et messieurs permettez moi de
vous remercier bien sûr ballon a accepté
de participer à ces échanges ont vu de
la discussion au sein de notre
commission d'un plan de relance
issu de nos rangs et bien sûr bientôt du
gouvernement il ressort des multiples
auditions j'allais dire presque des
centaines d'auditions menées par les
membres de notre commission que la crise
économique que nous traversons depuis
quelques mois va très vraisemblablement
s'installer dans la durée autrement dit
elle n'est pas dernière nous mais
vraisemblablement de vendre à court
terme
elle est le fruit bien sûr d'un choc
exogène contraignant les pouvoirs
publics à des mesures drastiques
stoppant brutalement la demande et
contraignant l'offre à se contracter en
conséquence sa croissance annuelle ma
chute est terriblement 8% les dépôts de
bus
lent et les plans sociaux s'annoncent
nombreux les chiffres du chômage
augmente avec déjà plus de huit cent
mille chômeurs supplémentaires les
finances publiques tant au niveau local
que national se dégrade ce n'est donc
pas une surprise la perspective d'une
crise passagère suivie d'un rebond
rapide semble malheureusement s'éloigner
et la crise semble devoir persister du
fait de la baisse durable de la
consommation liée à la constitution
d'une épargne de précaution je pense que
nous y viendrons et d'une diminution
importante de l'investissement la
consommation comme l'investissement
d'ailleurs où repose sur un élément
immatériel qui est fondamental qui est
la confiance tous les plans de relance
seront vains si cet élément essentiel
n'est pas retrouvée vous pourrez donc
tous les quatre nous indiquer quelles
sont selon vous les outils dont
disposent les pouvoirs publics afin
d'agir sur cet élément difficilement
mesurables et difficilement
appréhendables par ailleurs vous pourrez
également vous indiquer par quels moyens
il est possible d'agir sur la
consommation
bien sûr en volume mais aussi sur la
nature peut-être de cette consommation
sur le type de produits consommés sur
ces évolutions
alors que les débats sont vifs
actuellement à la fois sur la
responsabilité du consommateur mais
aussi sur son pouvoir d'achat et je
connais un de vos quatre dents c'est
évidemment le cheval de bataille depuis
quelques années la chute de
l'investissement parallèlement elle
fourbit maison de facteurs l'assèchement
des trésoriers des entreprises surtout
des pme
la baisse de leur solvabilité du fait
des mesures de soutien qui me soulans
pris la forme de report de paiement ou
de prêts qui viennent accroître leur
endettement et enfin d'une anticipation
d'une demande qu'on imagine hatton nous
aimerions donc connaître dans un premier
temps plus propres anticipations quant à
ces deux variables dans cette chute de
l'investissement la salle de la
consommation soit durable si oui quels
sont les événements et les les éléments
pardon et les leviers qui permettent de
les relancer de façon ces quatre
seraient selon vous les domaines
prioritaires
derrière ces questions il y a la
question du rôle de l'état
faut-il renouer avec les méthodes
d'intervention classiques relance
budgétaire et fiscale prise de
participation de l'état aux entreprises
en difficulté nous voyons bien sûr
l'état venir au secours des refrains ou
de renault je suis bien placé pour le
savoir
la crise va accroître les inégalités
justifie sans doute des politiques
sociales également plus ambitieux
prévention du chômage de longue durée en
particulier il y à là renouveau la
dépense publique qui tranche avec les
objectifs de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire affichée est souhaitée il y a
quelques mois
au delà d'une relance conjoncturelle
sirmet sont-ils soutenable longtemps
j'ai peur de connaître la réponse et
surtout sont ils efficaces dans des
économies aussi ouverte que la nôtre
j'ai tendance à penser que nous
retrouverons la croissance et l'emploi
aussi grâce à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises aux gammes parts de marché
sur le territoire national sur le
territoire européen mais aussi extra
européens
dans cette perspective qu attendez-vous
tous les quatre d'un plan de relance
enfin ce plan de relance doit
probablement être l'occasion de prendre
des mesures beaucoup plus structurelle
aussi je souhaiterais avoir votre point
de vue sur les mesures qui vous semble
souhaitable en matière de charges dont
réglementation mais aussi d'organisation
de l'état d'une façon générale alors
pour nous éclairer je vous propose dans
un premier temps de vous laisser la
parole chacun votre tour aux mêmes
périodes entre 5 et 10 minutes comme
vous souhaitez et dans un ordre
alphabétique qui exclut la galanterie je
suis puis à la suite de ces
interventions nous aurons peut-être un
débat est en tout cas mes collègues vous
formerons des questions que je souhaite
courte et direct et sur demande
également d'indiquer à qui il souhaite
adresser leurs questions
voilà et sans galanterie mais pardon les
faibles éthique je souhaite donc je cède
donc sans plus tarder la parole à michel
edouard leclerc bons jeux géants temps
de démarrer pardon pardon vous comme ça
pour vous rappeler que pour nous on est
encore
dans la crise c'est à dire que même si
nous participons volante ikea au coup
d'après à la lecture du monde d'après ou
et plus techniquement encore à l'énoncé
plan de sortie de crise et de relance
surtout de la croissance
nous sommes encore nous jusqu'au mois de
septembre octobre dans dans la crise
c'est à dire que d'ici là je suis au
siège des centres leclerc
il ya à peu près 10% des effectifs fin
juillet on sera à 40% d éjecter des
effectifs et l'ensemble du personnel ne
regagnera les lieux que fin septembre à
peu près donc sur le plan de
l'organisation du travail
nous sommes en gestion de crise nous
sommes dans la crise et je dirais que
même si nous secteur alimentaire
distribution dans le secteur alimentaire
on a quand même une sacrée vision de la
gestion de tout ça de la manière dont on
est rentré de la rapidité dans lesquels
on s'est adapté et dont on va sortir
il ne faut pas oublier que mon point de
vue doit tenir compte des collègues qui
viennent juste de rouvrir notamment je
parle du secteur de la distribution des
biens physiques non alimentaire mon
voisin juste en face c'est la fnac
enrique martinez vient d'ouvrir de
recouvrir ces flaques darty il ya toutes
les grandes les grandes enseignes de
l'électroménager des kills des biens
d'équipement de la maison ils ont subi
une crise encore plus forte depuis ce
qu'ils étaient fermés ils ont loupé la
saison textile ils ont loupé la la
saison de l'équipement des salons de
jardin etc
et puis bien sûr il ya tout le secteur
des services qui sont présents dans nos
centres commerciaux qui sont présents
dans nos magasins qui sont bien sûr
présents au coeur des villes et dans
l'animation de notre urbanité qu'il ne
faut qu'une viennent du werc depuis hier
soir
donc en fait en discute beaucoup entre
nous nous sommes encore
dans je dirais la paranoïa de la crise
dans les injonctions contradictoires
dans la lisibilité du plan de sortie
j'ai insiste là-dessus parce que c'est
quand même un exercice un peu compliqué
que de se projeter le temps d'après tout
en étant encore le nez dans le guidon
puisque j'ouvre je voudrais en profiter
pour dire qu' il y a au delà de deux des
aspects sanitaires médicaux des aspects
des drames sociaux que qu'on a tous
connus pardon on a connu les chiffres
par les médias et dont on a connu aussi
des personnes sur le plan économique et
sur le plan technique cette gestion de
la crise nous a permis d'apprendre
beaucoup de choses c'était complètement
on l'a dit inédit pour nous tous moi
j'ai 40 ans de bouteille dans la
distribution 40 ans dont je veux fêter
l'anniversaire cette année j'ai connu
pas mal de crise et même jeu les
souvenirs de crise du temps de mon père
la cli jabil les pénuries alimentaires
etc
on n'a jamais connu une crise de cette
dimension impliquant l'ensemble des
opérateurs économiques l'ensemble des
chaînes d'approvisionnement et je trouve
que globalement par exemple pour ce qui
est des biens de grande consommation
ça a été plutôt bien géré vous voyez les
distributeurs dont tout le monde sait
qu'il se livrer à une guerre des prix et
à une bataille
je dirais très masculine de part de
marché finalement on réussit à se parler
ont beaucoup parlé
nous avons parlé en amont beaucoup avec
les transporteurs avec les agriculteurs
avec les producteurs avec l'ania
l'association nationale des industriels
de l'agroalimentaire
tout ça a été finalement très positif il
ya des choses positives qui sont nés de
cette crise c'est ce retour à un
dialogue qu'on avait perdue depuis
plusieurs années
dialogues aussi avec les pouvoirs
publics
parce que même si il y a eu des des
différences de points de vue parce que
traitent chacun travaillait comme dans
l'entreprise privée chacun travail en
silo au ministère de la santé à
l'intérieur ou à bercy
nous c'est plutôt l'équipe de bruno le
maire c'est plutôt l'équipe de bercy qui
étaient en lien avec nous et qui a fait
le relais même sur les mesures de
sécurité sur les organisations du
travail tout ça finalement abouti à des
cahiers des charges assez rapidement
élaboré où le politique était à la fois
gendarme mes accompagnateurs et ça s'est
fait sans je pense trop de problème
déontologique et donc tout ce qui est
traitement sanitaire de la crise
traitement social du dispositif jeu et
approvisionnement des français
rappelez-vous les polémiques sur les
pénuries pénurie au départ sur la
nourriture pénurie sur les masques
finalement on a fait le job
on a fait le job nous distributeurs je
trouve qu'on a fait le job et l'ensemble
de la chaîne publique et privée a fait
le job
c'est important pour le pour demain
parce que ça veut dire qu'on est prêt à
travailler sur un plan de croissance
même si nous ne sommes pas nous mêmes
directement bénéficiaire même si nous ne
sommes pas les premiers de cordée
je pense que tous les acteurs des
filières aujourd'hui et monsieur martin
le sait puisque de son bureau son parti
pas mal de whatsapp et 2 et 2,2 de lieux
des changes je pense que tout le monde a
conscience aujourd'hui que personne ne
se sentira tout seul alors du point de
vue de la consommation s'est pas
complètement reparti mais ça repart ça
repart
assez fort avec des chiffres trompeurs
il ne faut pas l'oublier c'est que les
taux de croissance positif de la
consommation dans nos magasins
aujourd'hui même si c'est inégale selon
les régions reflète d'abord la fermeture
de deux des secteurs de
de restauration collective dont un
million huit cent mille enfants sont
encore dans les foyers et
s'approvisionne en hypermarché donc les
chiffres d'affaires des grandes
enseignes de distribution et sont très
positifs mais si on l'édition défalque
de ce transfert de marché je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il soit positif mais toujours est
il que la croissance reparte
les consommateurs sont dans les magasins
les hypermarchés ont été très touchés
par cette crise ils n'ont pas retrouvé
leur niveau d'avant beaucoup
d'hypermarchés ont perdu 40 à 60 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires mais aussi les
centres commerciaux ont perdu leur loyer
pour pas mal de sources de revenus aura
tout ça n'est qu'économique par rapport
à l'aspect sanitaire mais néanmoins
avant que ça ne revienne à la normale à
moi ou 2 mai mais les chiffres mes
collaborateurs nos collaborateurs pense
que de ce point de vue là globalement la
consommation va retirer va retrouver son
rang et va tirer la croissance la
croissance pendant la course le
confinement n'est pas un bon indicateur
de ce qui va se passer pour moi
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
écrites y compris par les grilles par
kantar sur à juste titre ce qui s'est
passé pendant la période de confinement
ne peut pas trop s'en servir pour la
projection
car c'était vraiment une parenthèse une
période inédite
il s'est fait il s'est acheté tout est
un peu n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs le
contraire de ce qu'ils achetaient avant
à moins de deux traditionnels moines bio
plus de pattes plus de riz des choses
qui se conserve mais ça on connaît c'est
le réflexe de survie de conservation
mais je pense que ça faut pas s'appuyer
là dessus pour faire des projections
mon analyse c'est que la consommation
qui est le modèle français de
consommation qui est volée qui évolue à
20 qui était plus qualitatif et partant
plus rémunérateurs pour le système de la
production et plus et agricoles parce
que créateur de plus de valeur ajoutée
ce trend va être accéléré et conforté
par la crise et simplement
aux critères de traçabilité de qualité
des produits de relocalisation en tout
cas de maîtrise de la notion de
l'approvisionnement va s'ajouter un
critère très forte qui est celui de la
sécurisation sécurisation du produit
sécurisation des modalités de vente
je pense que j'étais affolée hier soir
de voir que place des invalides et au
champ-de-mars y avait pas de masque mais
je pense que ça c'est que c'est ces
critères dans les sociétés à z
asiatiques se sont très bien installés
et même en allemagne en autriche et je
pense que la sécurisation dans l'acte
d'achat va s'installer et va jouer sur
la consommation donc en gros à ce stade
je vais me taire de après c'est je pense
pas qu'ils aient besoin d'une politique
globale de soutien de la demande
en revanche deux aspects la première
évidemment faut recréer de la confiance
et de l'attractivité sur des offres pour
faire désépargner les français et
ramener ces sommes vers le dispositif de
consommation et la deuxième chose c'est
que quand même cette crise a fait
apparaître que les produits français
étaient bien plus cher et bien plus cher
que tout ce qu'on pouvait dire en tant
que citoyen oui nous sommes prêts à
acheter des produits plus français où il
faut relocaliser mais si vous regardez
les commentaires sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux et dans les magasins et
les services consommateurs ont des dents
des écarts de prix de 20 à 30% sur des
produits de consommation quelle que soit
la manière dont chacun justifier les
hausses de prix c'est un vrai sujet non
pas pour les les trois quarts l'ailé les
les trois quarts des français
disons qu'ils ont des revenus plus
substantiels mais ceux qui ont des
revenus plus bas aujourd'hui vont ne
vont pas rentrer dans ce processus là ça
a été une révélation pour eux on a été
dans l'agressivité dans certains
magasins sur le prix des fraises sur le
prix des tomates etc
donc je ne crois pas pour répondre vous
commencez à répondre à votre question
qu'ils aient besoin d'un politique de
soutien
à la demande au delà de cibler des
catégories de population moins aisés qui
aimait qu'on pourrait soutenir et il
faudra discuter des moyens mais d'une
manière générale
moi je pense que la consommation va
retrouver son rythme merci beaucoup de
ces premiers de ses premiers propos je
vais passer donc la parole maintenant à
patrick martin président délégué du
medef
bonjour monsieur martin bonjour je
voudrais d'abord préciser que outre mais
mes fonctions de président délégué du
medef et des vols je suis avant tout
chef d'entreprise avait peut-être d'une
ati qui est également vite oublié a
constitué les choses dans une activité
qui nous met au contact de l'ensemble
des secteurs construction de l'industrie
des services pour entreprises - 23 et
demi pour cent de chez d'affaires au
mois de mars avec quinze jours de
confinement -43 et demi au mois d'avril
et nous finissons le mois de mer positif
ça m'amène à quelle réflexion ça m'amène
à dire que il faut dans l'analyse que
nous faisons de la situation et les
projections que l'on était monde et
d'abord il faut faire preuve de beaucoup
de prudence parce que on est face à une
situation totalement inédite au niveau
mondial singulièrement au niveau france
est face à laquelle on me dira
intellectuellement à 6 min alors ça doit
pas pour autant nous amener à être les
purges observateur ou un sperme en
conjectures il faut effectivement
prendre prendre des options pour ce qui
concerne le medef est dense et
quelques-unes de nos propositions phares
qui ont été présentées jeudi dernier le
ce qui sous-tend définitive un autre
stratégie c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prise de conscience pour reconstruire
refonder et protéger en toile de fond il
s'agit en aucun cas de rentrer dans une
polémique qui n'est pas de circonstance
et qui à vrai dire rapporte pas grand
chose il faut quand même souligner une
forme d'un
préparation de l'état bien sûr dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire avec ce
défaut de masques et respirateurs qui a
conduit à ce que l'économie française
sur décision de l'état s'arrête beaucoup
plus vite et beaucoup plus fort que
n'importe quel autre économie au sein de
l' ocde et ça n'a pris que 48 heures il
était légitime de prioriser à outrance
la sécurité sanitaire nous observent que
on ne reparle d'économique véritablement
depuis trois semaines ou un mois dans le
discours public mais la faiblesse
principale de l'état c'est surtout c'est
surtout la situation des finances
publiques qui bien évidemment réduit nos
marges de manoeuvre et qui conduit
notamment à ce que les dispositifs ont
été mis en place qui sont pertinents
qu'ils sont puissants quand tu étais
bien déployer je pense régulièrement à
l'activité partielle et au pga pour
autant tous ces dispositifs sont
sensiblement en proportion du pib
inférieur à ce que par exemple
l'allemagne de faire que ce soit à
travers l'état ou à travers les länder
notamment parce que les finances
publiques allemandes avant l'émergence
de cette crise gravissime les finances
publiques allemandes étaient donc en
meilleure santé si on peut dire en
france ça conduit d'ailleurs à ce que
nous nous interrogions avec une forme
d'inquiétude sur un redémarrage ou coups
plus puissants et beaucoup plus solide
en termes d'assistance hier de la part
de dpi que j'évoque et singulièrement
des maris ou bien illustrer mon propos
sur la comparaison entre le niveau je
dirais d'arrêt des économies dans le
bâtiment et les travaux publics en
france on est tombés au pire de la crise
à 10% de l'activité normale
l'allemagne n'est jamais tombé à -2 81%
donc l'avant ce qui pouvait exister
avant la crise risque de s'amplifier
après la crise
donc il nous appartient d'être être
extrêmement puissant et déterminé
bon pour ce qui concerne nos
propositions
j'entends avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce que
vient de dire à michel edouard leclerc
sur la reprise de la consommation
c'est vrai que les tous derniers
chiffres
mais avec la prudence que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure mérite d'être interprétée
positivement à des boutiques mans michel
edouard évoqué le champ-de-mars et
l'esplanade des invalides même quartier
hier soir les terrasses de restaurants
est habituellement bondées d'ailleurs
sans que les mesures de sécurité
sanitaire ce véritablement que je
respecte et je pense que ça traduit une
appétence de la part de la population
qui a été disciplinés pendant la période
de confinement mais qui manifestement
aspire à revivre comme elle le faisait
auparavant ça n'enlèvera rien à ce qu'a
dit à michel edouard sur la nécessité de
soutenir en particulier la consommation
on est confronté il ya beaucoup de
psychologie il a presque de subjectivité
dans cette affaire on est confronté à
une double crainte de la part de nos
concitoyens nous en partie des
concitoyens
il ya la crainte sanitaire qui semble se
dissiper au fil des jours on observe
dans tous les sondages mais qui pour
autant reste beaucoup plus fortes chez
les csp - que chez les csp + notamment
parce que chez les salariés
la première ligne est ce qu'on appelait
la première ligne mais également la
deuxième ligne se sont beaucoup des
employés les cadres eux mêmes et ont été
essentiellement au télétravail il faut
d'ailleurs faire attention à cette
fracture au sein de au sein de la
population qui conduit c'est pas bien
mais qui conduit à ce que certains
considèrent comme étant très exposé et
d'autres beaucoup moins
la deuxième crainte à laquelle on est
confronté c'est la crainte du chômage et
de la crise économique généralement et
de la même manière on voit dans les
sondages émergé progressivement cette
préoccupation qui est malheureusement de
nos points de vue que fondée il ya des
points sociaux qui ont d'ores et déjà
été annoncées il y en a sans qu'on
puisse trahir de secrets d'ailleurs on
ne sait pas tout mais des sexes
il y en a qui sont en préparation et qui
au delà des personnes directement
concernées par ces plans sociaux
impacteront très fortement la mentalité
des consommateurs avec un risque à
partir de là la consommation ne
redécolle pas vraiment et que l'épargné
considérable qui a été accumulée pendant
la période de confinement un peu forcé
de se
ne se libère pas donc dans nos
propositions on a différents différents
axes pour caler les principaux sont les
suivants il faut effectivement libéré
cette épargne à la fois bénéfice de la
consommation et au bénéfice de
l'investissement on a justement propos
on a notamment proposé deux choses la
première c'est 106 qualité les salariés
puissent disposer dès à présent de la
participation et de l'intéressement des
réserves de participation et
d'intéressement on parle quand même de
plusieurs milliards d'euros
mais également mettre en place ce qu'on
a fait un éco chèques inspiré d'un
dispositif qui existe déjà en belgique
réservé aux bas revenus et qui a un
double avantage d'abord ça donne un coup
de pouce à la consommation avec bien sûr
un coût pour l'état mais ensuite ça
oriente cette consommation des produits
verts j'y reviendrai il ya effectivement
dans le débat les débats qui nous anime
plus encore qu'avant peu vide
cette préoccupation environnementalistes
qui est importante
depuis par ailleurs il faut libérer
l'épargné au bénéfice du refinancement
de l'économie à la fois pour
l'investissement public
ces collectivités locales vont être
durement affectée en terme de ressources
fiscales notamment sur les entreprises
alors même qu' elles représentent plus
de 70% de l'investissement public en
face on va avoir besoin
d'investissements en infrastructures que
ce soit l'infrastructure de transport ou
d'infrastructures digital mais également
libéré l'épargné pour venir au nous
venir au secours des entreprises en
particulier des très nombreuses
entreprises qui ayant accumulé des
nattes que ce soit au titre des reports
de charges ou au titre du pg auront de
la difficulté à rembourser
on va faire face à ses échéances
notamment pour les nombreuses
entreprises qui sont d'une part
confronté à un problème de demande a
lancé pts pas sur les produits de grande
consommation je ne reviens pas sur ce
point là mais plutôt sur des biens
d'équipement typiquement dans
l'aéronautique dans l'automobile dans le
tourisme le problème de la demande reste
reste une question absolument essentiel
en tuera d'une part des problèmes de
niveau d'activité dans commandes de ce
secteur
d'autre part un problème de productivité
donc de rentabilité lié notamment à la
mise en place des mesures de sécurité
sanitaire notre estimation c'est qu'en
moyenne des secteurs d'activités que ce
soit dans l'industrie dans le bâtiment
que dans la construction ou dans les
services la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositions qui sont absolument
nécessaires pénalise la productivité de
l'ordre de 20%
donc si vous avez d'un côté une demande
insuffisante si vous avez d'un autre
côté des coûts de production qu'il
augmente nécessairement les rentabilités
les capacités d'autofinancement est
durement affectée et à partir de là un
certain nombre d'entreprises auront du
mal à faire face à ses échéances
sociales et fiscales ou de remboursement
des pg donc les banques qui je le
signale au passage ne bénéficient pas de
la garantie de l'état dans
l'appréciation de leurs ratios
bilanciels curieusement pas la
réglementation bancaire
curieuse les banques ne pourront pas
éternellement porter ccpg en termes de
ratios
et puis tout simplement de risque pour
ce qui les concerne donc il faut
réorienter de l'épargné vers le
financement de l'économie
il n'est pas interdit de penser je sais
que en particulier gérald darmanin il
réfléchit en tout cas nous on avait fait
une proposition dans ce sens avec un
avantage fiscal on puisse fléchés vers
des quasi fonds propres
l'épargné des particuliers qui est
abondante et qui n'ira pas vers la
consommation s'agissant des catégories
socioprofessionnelles les plus nantis le
deuxième le deuxième point sur lequel il
faut absolument se focaliser c'est bien
évidemment le marché de l'emploi avec
déjà un thème urgentissime et celui de
l'accueil des jeunes à la rentrée
les sept cent mille jeunes qui vont
arriver sur le marché de l'emploi
compte tenu des perspectives d'activité
tout à craindre les entreprises ne
puisse pas recruter en tout à
massivement tous ces jeunes qui arrivent
ça nous
conduit à faire une proposition d
exonération charge sur un an où vit une
circonstance exceptionnelle on se doit
de prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
même si la situation financière que ce
soit de la sécurité sociale de l'unedic
se trouve extrêmement dégradée il faut
qu'on prenne des mesures de soutien à
l'emploi déjà donc exonérations de
charges comme première année pour tout
premier cdi signée avec agen et puis il
ya un sujet également extrêmement
sensible de l'apprentissage
on doit tous se réjouir de la bonne
trajectoire
enfin de payer les clients en la matière
avec augmentation de 16% du nombre
d'apprentis à la rentrée 2010 9 de la
même manière les enquêtes pour faire
auprès de nos adhérents sont extrêmement
peur on peut le comprendre un bon nombre
de chefs d'entreprise même s'ils sont en
leur for intérieur convaincu de
l'apprentissage est une bonne solution
non seulement pour les jeunes et leurs
familles pour le pays des pôles et leur
entreprise également ne priorise ment
pas l'intégration d'apprentis à la
rentrée prochaine alors même que les
inscriptions se font en ce moment je
vais pas détailler les propositions
qu'on a fait bon sens mais on les tient
à votre disposition
il faut absolument là aussi envoyé un
signal très fort parce que sinon ça
viendra évidemment sur ajouter au taux
de chômage qui est en train de grimper
en flèche vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure à la présidente
mais ça peut ça peut présenter un risque
social et politique extrêmement grave
on a tous les entreprises au premier
chef une responsabilité éminente au
regard de cette jeunesse ensuite il ya
tout lieu de s'interroger sur une
manière un peu abusive de mon point de
vue on a appelé le jour d'après c'est ce
qu'on appelle nous dans notre voulait
refonder pour votre information le medef
a mis en place un comité en renaissance
qui est constitué d'une vingtaine
d'experts qui ne sont pas des chefs
d'entreprises qui sont de grands
intellectuels si je vous tenir le
quelques mystères en essence et présidé
parole enrico letta l'ancien président
du conseil italien
ce qui n'est pas un différent parce que
dans toutes nos réflexions dans toutes
vos propositions
on a
dimension européenne qui est extrêmement
santé nous restons plus que jamais
convaincu que la france sans l'europe ne
s'en sortira pas en matière de
financement mais également en matière de
stratégie digitale en matière de
stratégie environnement typiquement la
mise en place absolument nécessaire
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone de taxe
carbone aux frontières ne peut se
concevoir qu'au niveau européen avec
toutes les difficultés qu'on sait de
consensus au sein des pays de l'union
européenne il ya trois grands défis
auxquels on est rapidement confronté
celui des relocalisations et je reprends
complètement ce que disait michel
edouard auparavant tu la réaction qui
peut paraître anecdotique des
consommateurs face à l'augmentation du
prix des friends
malheureusement symptomatique de ce qui
risque de se passer d'une manière
générale on a d'un côté une aspiration
très forte partagé par les chefs
d'entreprise en faveur de la
relocalisation mais chacun devant gérer
ses contradictions
ça n'a de sens que si ces
relocalisations sont compétitives je
prends un exemple on doit tous se réunir
et le meeddat qui a contribué de 350
industriels du textile se soit hexagoal
tour reconverti dans la production
masque ça a contribué à desserrer l'étau
sanitaires à part que les masques
produits en france coûte cinq à six fois
plus cher que les masques produits au
vietnam ou en chine parce que demain le
la sidération
l'urgence est à dissiper s'agissant de
la crise sanitaire
nous serons prêts à acheter des masques
au motif qu'ils sont français cinq à six
fois plus cher que ceux produits en
chine et de la même manière plus
fondamentalement c'est vrai de l'acier
c'est vrai des médicaments donc ça
renvoie à cette nécessité impérieuse de
restaurer la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises
sinon ne gérera pas cette équation
compétitivité relocalisation ça renvoie
immanquablement au sujet des impôts de
production ça renvoie aussi un deuxième
sujet qui est celui du partage de la
richesse
cette ce discours émerge puissamment il
existait déjà
d'une nécessaire rééquilibrage de la
richesse en france on perd un petit peu
de vue dans cette affaire que la france
est un des pays au monde où après
transferts sociaux
la répartition des richesses et la plus
égalitaire
on perd également de vue que la france
est le pays au monde loin des deux pays
au monde où les prélèvements
obligatoires sont les plus élevés on
perd en fin de vie ce sujet qui
économiquement est anecdotique mais qui
politiquement extrêmement sensible de la
fiscalité du patrimoine
les interrogations sur l'is f dans une
moindre mesure sur le déneigement
forfaitaire unique sont de notre point
de vue assez malsain parce que même
moment l'ua falloir renforcer les fonds
propres des entreprises et
singulièrement de beaucoup de pme et tpe
si on envoie un signal très négatif aux
investisseurs ont compliquera encore la
résolution de ce problème qui va être
absolument central de reconstitution et
de renforcement des fonds propres des
entreprises
donc il faut appréhender sujet de la
répartition de la richesse avec beaucoup
de rationalité et en essayant de ne pas
tomber en quelque sorte dans des débats
qui qui sont décalés par rapport à
l'urgence économique et sociale à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
enfin le troisième grand défi auquel on
est confronté c'est évidemment celui de
verdissement de notre économie sujet sur
lequel les entreprises le medef sont
extrêmement motivés les sujets qu'il ya
un coût donc il faut là aussi qu'on
trouve le bon équilibre
on ne mélange pas absolument tous les
sujets pour nous l'impératif
environnemental incontournable mais
l'impératif économique et social urgent
il est encore plus donc on est en train
de réfléchir il faut qu'on réfléchisse
tous ensemble tous ensemble aux bons
réglages en quelque sorte qu'il faut
opérer entre ces différents impératifs
là aussi le rôle de l'union européenne
va être absolument déterminant en termes
de stratégie j'évoquais tout à l'heure
la taxe aux frontières la taxe carbone
aux frontières pardon mais également en
terme de
obtient de financement je veux dire par
là que le débat qui est assez franco
français sur le jour d'après est ce que
cette crise violente et durable du coc
vide va occasionner une remise à plat
complète de notre économie modèle social
ou est ce que au contraire par phénomène
de résilience
on reviendra essentiellement ou au
comportement des organisations
antérieures c'est c'est pas vrai débat
nous notre préoccupation ce débat soit
appréhendé donc beaucoup de beaucoup de
sang froid beaucoup de détermination
mais en étant en ayant une approche
globale de ces différences
voilà je ne détaille pas les 40 autres
propositions que nous avons formulées
mais conclut en disant que pour nous le
vrai problème
à la rentrée il être à la rentrée parce
que donc il y aura ces échéances
fiscales sociales il y aura ces
problèmes de niveau d'activité et de
rentabilité des entreprises
puis je finis sur un sujet qui passe
assez inaperçu mais tait absolument
central pour les entreprises qui est
celui du crédit interentreprises qui
s'est beaucoup contractée pendant la
période
c'est normal l'activité elle même
beaucoup contractée par définition moins
de créances entre les entreprises les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
jusque là par les pouvoirs publics sont
sensiblement insuffisant par rapport aux
encours je rappelle simplement que le
crédit interentreprises
c'est trois fois plus qu'en temps normal
trois fois plus que les crédits
bancaires de court terme
on conseille on y contribuent beaucoup
au medef que bercy est en train de
réfléchir à un dispositif d'ailleurs
directement inspiré de ce qu'ont fait
les allemands et qui permettrait de
libérer en quelque sorte ces entreprises
en apportant des garanties beaucoup plus
puissantes au aux assureurs crédit
pardon d'évoquer ce sujet qui peut
passer pour très technique
à nouveau c'est un enjeu économique
considérable la preuve en est que en
2009 2010
un des principaux facteurs de
ralentissement même de récession ça a
été le crédit interentreprises et pour
finir de finir bien évidemment ça ne
surprendra pas de notre part de ma part
mais ça mérite quand même d'être
souligné la solution pour nous ne doit
pas ne peut pas passer par une
augmentation de la fiscalité là aussi il
faut tirer les enseignements de
l'histoire entre 2010 et 2013
je le rappel sous 2 présidence de la
république différentes les finances
publiques avait tenté d'avoir
rééquilibré par une augmentation des
prélèvements obligatoires ça a eu un
effet catastrophique pour nous la bonne
solution
elle est d'augmenter la base fiscale
donc de soutenir contre vents et marées
l'activité la consommation et
l'investissement
merci merci beaucoup c'est martin
j'imagine que vous proposeront faire
réaliser un grand nombre de nos
collègues sur effectivement un certain
nombre de propositions vous faites et
qui engendre évidemment des dépenses
fiscales et des dépenses de l'état c'est
important évidemment sur recettes en
face à face au déficit de l'état que
vous dénoncez au départ mais nous
verrons ça dans la deuxième partie
là aussi et des injonctions probablement
contradictoires je passe la parole à
xavier ragot président de l'oued cej
remercie de sa présence messieurs ragoût
là oui bonjour merci bonjour comme tout
académique et observateurs j'ai quelques
transparent je ne sais pas si je peux
les projeter pour appuyer mon propos qui
sera plutôt affirmatif donc voilà on les
a ou les a envoyé à chacun des de nos
collègues mais on va avoir du mal à les
projeter en tout cas bougeait pas la
technique que la norme il suffit de le
mettre
co animateur de la réunion et dans ces
cas là je veux sans partage sur jours
donc il faut à droite alors on va on va
demander ça jonathan dubas voilà c'est
déjà fait l'a priori donc voila vous
regardez la technologie moderne à quel
point c'est magnifique
merci beaucoup de conviction merci
beaucoup
donc je pense que maintenant vous voyez
mais transparent bien on ne vous voit
plus on voit vos transparent
sont beaucoup plus intéressant que moi
je vous assure cette crise est très
intéressante et on la comprend pas et on
voit que tous les acteurs pivote autour
de rhétorique passé j'ai beaucoup aimé
le disque aux quatre roues qui a précédé
et madame la présidente ce que vous avez
noté la l'évolution je me permettrai
mais je un débat à venir des positions
du medef que j'ai trouvé très stimulante
qui vont à la fois dansant de plus
d'être public et de moindres plus de
dépenses publiques de fait plus d'être
sectorielle cibler ces questions
environnementales et sociales et en même
temps un de hausse de la fiscalité ce
qui veut dire bien sur un court terme
une augmentation de la dette
donc il ya maintenant un consensus
autour de l'utilisation des instruments
publics comme la dette publique à court
terme pour stabiliser l'économie
c'est une impression mais que je vais
acté pour des bonnes raisons donc j'ai
commencé dans le temps qui est un parti
je vais pas vous noyez deux chiffres je
ne voudrais pas je voudrais juste
argumenté un petit peu mon propos pour
faire écho à ce qui a été dire beaucoup
de choses qui sont en écho de ce qui a
été dit notamment à michel edouard
leclerc sur la dynamique de consommation
à côte
c'est alors déjà j'ai essayé de partir
de ce qu'on sait déjà de cette crise
parce que c'est vrai que l'on déjà on a
du bien de comprendre la singularité de
sa crise c'est pas la crise de 2008
c'est pas la crise de mai 68 car
empêcher la consommation et c'est encore
moi la crise de 2009 de 1929 il ya
quelque chose de vraiment singulier et
les observateurs ont du mal à comprendre
l'intensité de la crise qui fait que
vous avez vu que même les chiffres de
croissance à nos visions aussi court que
décembre 2020 sont passés de -8 à -11
récemment et il ya pour un débat
important sur ce chiffre là qui sera
essentiel pour avoir un l'assiette
fiscale la dette publique et donc
peut-être d'évolution la fiscalité
donc ce que l'on sait c'est que à cette
crise n'est pas ordinaire
je dirais assez brutalement parce que
l'état a bien réagi
alors l'état a bien réagi qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que aulas donc
est ce que vous voyez mais transparent
pas non vous revoir alors c'est ça saute
et d'anjou mme excusez moi c'est voilà
je reviens donc l'état bien réagit
essentiellement et essai à noter du fait
du voilier de notre ensemble voilà oui
absolument
oh ouais parce qu'elle a bien réagi et
s'est hissé à noter avec la référence
assez systématique à l'allemagne dans
cette dimension c'est qu'on a un peu
copié le dispositif allemand de la crise
de 2008 2013 qui est l'importation
massive du chômage partiel avec des taux
dont vous voyez le taux de recours de
leurs 2 8 millions de salariés au
chômage partiel une demande totale
maximale de leur demi million qu'est ce
que ça veut dire c'est à dire que dans
cette crise l'état a en moyenne assuré
en très très grande partie de revenus
des ménages france et je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres
mais les ménages français ont un revenu
d'activité qui somme toute a décrit un
tout petit peu de l'ordre de 7% en
moyenne avec des effets importants
d'inégalités je vais substance y est
alors que la consommation moyenne
française a chuté de l'ordre de 30% ce
qui veut dire au moment où on se parle
ce qui est vraiment inédit dans cette
crise c'est que les pales des français a
augmenté de 80 donc par rapport à toutes
les aides dont on parle
la principale variable clé de cette
sortie de crise sera effectivement
quelle fraction des 80 milliards
retournera dans les commerces dans
l'activité cet été dans le tourisme ça
change complètement
l'appréciation de cette crise quelque
part le plus grand moteur de la crise
s'est déclenchée les décisions de
consommation ces chiffres ce tableau
vous donnez un peu une compréhension de
la stratégie implicite française dans
cette crise qui a été révélé maintenant
par les chiffres qu'on connaît petit 1
on voit que ce qu'a fait l'état avec le
fond dead et l'assurance chômage
l'activité partielle en grande partie un
peu l'assurance chômage l'état a
transféré une grande partie de de la
perte du revenu du pib français qui est
de 180 milliards d'euros je donne des
grandes masses après je serai plus
précis n'a transfert la paire de 180
milliards elle a été portée par 60% par
l'administration publique
40 du fait de l'augmentation des dettes
publiques qui a limité la perte de
revenus des ménages d'à peu près 8 % et
les entreprises ont une perte de ménage
est saine avec ces sociétés non
financières et sociétés financières donc
l'ensemble du secteur privé et une perte
de revenus de valeur ajoutée de 30%
donc le sortie prise vous voyez que pour
le dira manière un peu brutale c'est que
à juste titre l'état était keynésien il
a soutenu le revenu des ménages ce qui a
fait dans une est dans une situation où
les ménages mais pas consommer ou
consommation n'est pas très importante
dont on avant l'activité est le secteur
qui a quelque part encaissé en grand
partie la crise ça a été les capacités
de financement des entreprises dont j'ai
parlé qui est maintenant à juste titre
l'attention principale de tous les
acteurs il faut élite et cette vague de
faillites à venir et je je je vais en
parler plus précisément ce chiffre-là
gucci dans les tableaux permettez-moi de
pas le détail et c'est pour votre
information pour voir qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé un point cependant assez
important que je veux dire c'est que on
va parler de comparaison internationale
et j'aurais pas le temps de détailler le
travail de l'insee et d'autres étaient
remarquables sur le plan international
lindsay a utilisé les données de carte
bleue en temps réel aux essayé d'estimer
la dynamique de consommation par
territoire secteur donc des données
françaises en terme de chute d'activité
sont une qualité peu comparable aux
douanes italiennes espagnoles et
allemandes ont lien très concrètement je
ne crois pas aux chiffres espagnol
allemand et italien
je pense beaucoup que les données
français sont une très grande qualité
dont ce qui est dit sur la consommation
des ménages est une très grande
l'idée par rapport à d'autres pays parce
que ces données de carte bleue sont
étonnés assez facile donc ce point pour
dire qu'une face au tableau le mal ce
qu'on arrive à voir c'est que la chute
d'activité par secteur et c'est ce qu'a
dit monsieur martin est forcément très
hétérogène on sait et qu'il ya des
secteurs qui sont contre à la demande et
vous voyez les secteurs et dans ce
travail assez inédit de l'eau et ce qui
sera qui est très préliminaire en corse
et toutes les équipes de l'ouest qu'on
travaillait en interaction et des
instituts statistiques et donc et très
préliminaire je le chiffre final seront
plus construit dans le futur mais vous
voyez que on a fait la stratégie de
confinement de déconfinement dans
différents scénarios et donc c'est des
prévisions jusqu'à début juillet de
cette année les chiffres que je vous dis
d'accord
donc vous voyez les deux rochers et des
secteurs j'ai pas rentrer dans les
détails je pense que c'est connu les
secteurs touchés sur le transport le
tourisme à la construction c'est connu
et ça donne forcément les l'actualité
des plans dead qui font beaucoup de
travaux de bercy en ce moment notre
lecture c'est que la plupart des
secteurs sont contraints par la demande
sauf quatre secteurs agriculture
industrie agroalimentaire construction
est un autre secteur qu'on oublie un
petit peu qu'ils aient les
administrations publiques mais qui est
important de faire ton et pays
c'est un secteur aussi qu'est contrat
par l'offre ces quatre secteurs son
contrat par l'offre du fait de
contraintes sanitaires d'après donc ces
chiffres là sont nés co2 forcément des
outils qu'il faut penser de l'action
publique et des notes tissu industriel
c'est pénible mais je vais recommencer
la démarche puisque je vois que mon que
l'on zoome sautent régulièrement et
c'est dommage je voudrais quand même
utilisé ces chiffres pour convaincre de
du bien fondé de excusez moi c'est le
coup de des interactions numériques est
assez grand voilà donc je pense que je
suis revenu voilà notre scénario de
dynamique de l'activité et saran voir ça
c'est intéressant et ça ne l'est pas je
voudrais dire entre des analystes aux
propos de michel edouard leclerc soit
dynamique
conserver son court terme vous voyez que
l'activité a chuté de 32% et que là dans
la ld confinement on a un retour de
l'activité contre la chute est bien
moindre et se pique c'est exactement ce
dont on parle et retour des
consommateurs dans les magasins dans les
terrasses de quatre filles ce pic est
important et plus important que je
compense donc beaucoup d'observateurs
sont stratégie de révision de la
profondeur de cette crise qu'on voit
comme l'accélération du retour à la
norme
le grand débat c'est est ce que cette
autre ce retour à la normale
c'est un flic transitoire après le
confinement ou est-ce que l'on va aller
vers un nouveau mode de consommation où
effectivement des contraintes sanitaires
dans les lieux de consommation emballés
d'un nouveau niveau de consommation
inférieur de celui qu'on connaissait
avant de l'ordre de 17 15 % mais quand
même stabilisé ce grand départ sa
consommation de court terme dans les cas
déterminés
là c'est là le chiffre de fin 2020 est
ce que c - 8 - 12 - 10 on n'en sait pas
grand chose
je pense que tous les acteurs le savent
aussi bien là la cour des comptes bercy
et donc c'est des scénarios prévisionnel
on ne sait pas grand chose bien et mon
premier poids lourd est son second point
c'est un point d'eux qu'est-ce qui fait
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
mon point c'est qu'il nous faut une
doctrine claire là je vous ai montré
toutes les bonnes idées et mon but c'est
pas de détails et c'est pour montrer le
petit problème qu'on a dans le débat
public un secteur là je n'ai mis que 20
mais j'aurais pu vous en mettre 60
toutes les bonnes idées alors
effectivement celle du medef sont en
partie des bonnes idées
je me permets cette remarque il ya les
écochèques il ya le prêt à taux zéro
lancé voir un taux négatif c'est le
secteur immobilier construction il ya
recapitalisant 32 stratégique et c'est à
raya il ya la prime à l'embauché
il ya beaucoup d'éléments ça coûte de
l'argent il nous faut une doctrine une
doctrine et je dirais que cette doctrine
a doit être sur deux piliers
la fois soutient la demande à soutien de
l'offre moi mon point de vue c'est que
la faillite intellectuelle française je
dirais en termes de politique économique
c'est d'avoir opposé la politique de
l'offre de la firme 2013 et hausses
d'impôts
on a fait avant avec des politiques soit
de la demande soit de l'offre alors
qu'il nous faut les deux c'est essentiel
nous foutent la consommation une faute
d'investissements la politique de
l'offre dans l'année qui vient
elle a un nom ça veut dire éviter les
faillites ça je pense ma lecture c'est
que les plans de redéfinir le monde
d'après il faut l'inclure aujourd'hui
mais la vague de faillites sera clef
dans l'issue de l'érosion profondeur si
productif
il faut malgré tout les fights le coeur
du capitalisme c'est les faillites c'est
la réallocation du capital en fonction
de l'évolution de la structure de
consommation et d'investissement
auxerre on doit aller vers une économie
verte une économie à sanitairement forte
donc quels sont les éléments de doctrine
et après je fais des propositions à il
faut sortir très progressivement des
mesures de soutien des ménages notamment
du chômage partiel pour pas que cette
épargne forcée se transforme en épargne
de précaution
il faut rassurer les ménages rassurer
les ménages sur la contrainte budgétaire
que l'état va passer un tour de vis sur
l'assurance chômage sur des facteurs
sinon les gens briques barnier ça va
créer des fêtes sortie très progressive
des instruments de soutien aux ménages
2 et ça a été dit et je tiens à le
souligner que par monsieur martin la
question des inégalités de ce côté
globale que j'ai dit les revenus des
ménages aidés soutenus saccage de très
fortes inégalités chez les plus pauvres
chez les jeunes chez les non qualifiés
dont la perte de revenus et en prime un
crucial les gens dans les quartiers qui
doivent nourrir leurs enfants alors
qu'ils allaient à l'école alors que la
cantine était quasiment gratuite
c'est un impact très important sur leurs
sur leur budget ces éléments là il faut
les mettre dans le débat parfois les
montants sont pas énormes mais en terme
humain social même politique le
rendement pour la cohésion pour la
confiance madame la présidente vous
parler c'est aussi ça l'acceptation et
la perception d'un coût partagé de cette
crise qui nous concernera bien ça c'est
sûr le
et ménages le côté entreprises la chute
de l'investissement les réelles mais
c'est une marge importante pour les
entreprises assure leur capacité de
financement
notre estimation est là je dois dire
pareil que ce que sur quoi travailles
beaucoup d'analystes
c'est tout et données d'entreprise nous
avons accès aux trois millions
d'entreprises et donc on peut prévoir
avec des hypothèses et des amis de
frites et de contraintes de liquidités
pour van wijk par secteur par taille
d'entreprises c'est l'exercice auquel
book où se se livre dans l'ouest
tous trois millions d'entreprises ça se
fait maintenant et on peut aiguiller les
cheveux notre analyse est la suivante on
observe une chute du quart de la
liquidité des entreprises des capacités
de financement de court terme
on a une augmentation des faillites qui
seront malgré le chômage partiel dont
qui permet de baisser les coûts des
entreprises de problèmes an à 2,75 1000
à 100 milles faillite bien au delà du
petit 2013 était de 63
ça entraîne une destruction permanente
d'emploi de l'ordre de 400 milles à
500000 bon qu'elle n'est rose ion
profond de l'emploi qui c'est qui est
souvent des emplois non qualifiés dans
des territoires parfois fragile
c'est un sujet macroéconomique sa
dynamique effect dans cette vision de la
doctrine qu'on ait cédé à laquelle
réfléchir à l'eau et ce pour cet aspect
offre ce à quoi on travaille c'est
d'essayer d'avoir une politique
alors excusez moi encore né à
l'allemande décide qu'on veut convaincre
des gens dit à la demande en général
l'impensable scène politique allemande
qui est de contribuer à payer les coûts
fixes des entreprises c'est-à-dire les
coûts d'immobilisation du capital les
loyers pour que la baisse d'activité
auquel elles sont absolument pas
responsables une partie des coûts fixes
soit socialiser payé par l'état pour
éviter les faillites
c'est économiquement moralement et
socialement probablement de l'ordre de
l'acceptable on a fait différente
analyse qui nous conduisent de l'ordre
de 17 7 milliards soit 1.2 pibe de
de coûts de compensation de capital fixe
à la consommation capital ficta
dotations aux amortissements je rentrais
dans les détails et ça avec ses bonnes
propriétés sectorielle on veut essayer
de se comporter donc un aider des
entreprises en socialisant les coûts
fixes dans le confinement de été les
ménages notamment les ménages et iii
bien sûr l'organisation sectorielle pour
adapter tissu productif et là ça renvoie
à l'intégration la contrainte économique
et environnemental avec les outils qui
doivent être au niveau du secteur
ce dont j'ai parlé avant sont des outils
trop transversaux aux vraiment mobilisé
coordonner les acteurs au niveau du
secteur
trois piliers donc soutien ménage avec
sortie très progressive des dispositifs
en place et gestion des inégalités de
payer les coûts fixes entreprises et
trois organisations sectorielles pour
intégrer la contrainte environnementale
entre autres alors le monde d'après
c'est mon dernier slide madame la
présidente pour sortir un peu plus la
généralité de notre de notre débat et je
les fais donc j'ai me livrer à cet
exercice mais retrait partiel parce que
tout le monde parle du monde d'après à
genève est très direct on nous disait
que la france est en faillite comme on a
des 60% de dette sur quillan je les lui
je ne sais plus qui j'ai oublié donc je
vais pas incriminer qui que ce soit
aujourd'hui on a 120 % des 2 sur steam
je n'oublie fragments on nous explique
que les gens sont trompés sur ce qu'on
pense à solidité de notre économie
la question c'est quelle est la bonne
dette qu'elle est la mauvaise dette
quelle est la dette de croissance et
qu'elle est la bête la dette de facilité
de mauvaise gestion bêta ou n'osent pas
ajuster le nahd est laxiste et la dette
d'investissement
l'urgence est de séparer les deux
l'audience est de séparer la dette du
code lead dans un support additionnel
une sorte de kds qu'ovide haut que ses
dettes du coc vite ne pèse pas sur les
choix d'investissements futurs
sinon on va parler de la dette publique
des impôts ça à polluer notre débat et
ça va faire ce qu'on est ce que les
entreprises connaissent un anglicisme
l'appel tête aux rings
c'est une entreprise trop endettés allez
mauvaise stratégie de court terme il
faut mieux purger la dette à
recapitaliser pour qu'elles dans le
futur au mieux à un moment à télé
hertz plutôt que les faire couler dans
le futur c'est exactement la même chose
presse gratuite français mieux vous
séparez la dette du co lead pour avoir
voir quelle est la date additionnel
qu'il faut pour investir en tissu
productif avec des contraintes
environnementales sanitaires et de
tissus productif et éviter les faillites
et je me suis permis de mettre melzer
entre parenthèse pour dire que je pense
que cinq ans sur lequel il en consensus
belle énergie
il ne faut ma lecture ce qu'il faut
arrêter de rentrer dans une notion
purement comptable dépenses publiques
sinon le débat il est permis comme elle
était perdue entre guillemets sa dette
publique avec une dramatisation
anti-économique de l'aide publique qui
n'a pas marché
si on veut réduire la dépense publique à
court terme on n'y arrivera pas il ya
une demande forte de dépenses sur la
question c'est faire pivoter le débat
vers la qualité de la dépense publique à
la qualité de leur eau marginal ou est
ce qu'on met l'argent public dans
l'hôpital dans l'éducation dans la
petite enfance dans les territoires donc
la question c'est un enveloppe constante
quelle que soit je pense des points de
vue c'est faire pivoter se débat dans le
débat public pour arriver à des
solutions et des compromis qui soit des
compromis acceptées sur tout le
territoire sont cruciales
c'est l'acceptabilité politique de tout
ce qu'on a à faire on sera dans un monde
endettés le vrai monde d'après c'est le
monde endettés tous les pays sont
incroyablement d'été on n'a jamais vu çà
d'entendre qui l'a 20 ans qui viennent
seront la gestion la dette publique
l'absorption comme après la seconde
guerre mondiale on a fait est là je
souligne avec plus d'accord là le
discours de monsieur martin en disant
que la meilleure lutte contre
l'endettement c'est d'augmenter la base
fiscale s'est axé la croissance
l'investissement et les développements
économiques
c'est ça qui est la façon dont on a
absorbé les dettes d'après guerre en
trente glorieuses sap a été par
l'austérité par des politiques de
croissance augmenter la base fiscale et
permis à la torsion la dette publique
est passée de 220 à 30% du pib' en 40
ans je le rappelle les heures de mandat
moi je vais pas aller trop loin dans ses
aliments très macroéconomique et je
pense que 1 ne pas dramatiser dette
publique ça va nous coûter une
génération d'absorber ces deux grandes
crises 2000
les cris du peuple c'est trop sérieux
quoi dramatiser et enfin la grande
question dans un monde très endetté on
fait pivoter la dette publique c'est
bien sûr si vous avez souligné
c'est redéfinition du rôle de l'état
dans l'économie ont laissé l'initiative
privée et répondre à l'évolution de la
demande
l'évolution des besoins sociaux et la
demande de croissance et d'emploi et en
même temps on sera dans un monde où
l'état sera beaucoup plus pivot ou
absorber ces dettes publiques et gérer
les questions sanitaires et absorber une
partie de la question sociale qui sera
aussi la dette sociale très importante
dans la gestion du club
merci gedo transparent je me tue à la
comparaison entre sienna les autres mais
je voudrais m'arrêter à ce niveau un peu
général de ta passion
merci beaucoup monsieur la gauche je
pense que vos propos pourront
naturellement réagir nos interlocuteurs
je vais donc de terminer cette table
ronde en donnant la parole agnès verdier
molinié qui est directrice denis frappe
et qui ne manquera pas je pense de
réagir à ce qu'elle vient à manquer
merci madame la présidente merci à tous
je vais essayer d'intervenir en cinq
points assez rapide
d'abord pour revenir sur les mesures
d'urgence avant le plan de
reconstruction et se poser les questions
de ce qu'on pourrait améliorer justement
pour éviter les faillites puisque c'est
ça qu'il faut arriver aujourd'hui
absolument à préserver notre tissu
entrepreneurial qui est tellement
tellement nécessaire et qui va être
tellement nécessaire dans les prochains
mois et là nous nous posons des
questions la fondation ifrap sur le fait
que l'état français n'ait pas proposé un
pg e garantie à 100% notamment sur les
tpe pme et nous proposons de revenir sur
ce sujet puisqu'il va y avoir une loi de
finances rectificative 3 on pourrait
très bien imaginer que ce soit possible
les allemands l'ont fait et ça peut
permettre aussi puisque il faut le
rappeler nos entreprises sont plus
embêtés hein que les entreprises
comparables en allemagne en espagne ou
en italie
donc elles sont déjà rentrés dans la
crise avec une difficulté supplémentaire
donc ce que nous proposons aussi c'est
que le pg e soit remboursable sur
beaucoup plus d'années
parce que aujourd'hui on s'est rendu
compte que ailleurs et notamment en
allemagne
on peut partir sur dix ans pour
rembourser son pg e avec deux ans de
non-remboursement deux ans sans
remboursement du tout et là il pourrait
y avoir une piste très intéressante qui
permettrait justement à nos entreprises
de continuer à investir de continuer à
se développer tout en ne craignant pas
le poids du remboursement de ce prêt
garanti par l'état par ailleurs on
réfléchit on a déjà fait des
propositions à ce que cette dette
pge ne plombe pas trop le ratio
d'endettement des entreprises et là
imaginer de le compter différemment pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que cela ne soit
pas dommageable en termes de ratio
d'endettement pour les prochaines années
pour pour nos entreprises par exemple
nous avons aussi proposé de suspendre
aussi le privilège du trésor et des
urssaf qui leur permet quand ils ont des
créances sur les entreprises récupérées
en priorité là ce serait une très bonne
chose pour éviter les faillites
d'entreprises
nous avons proposé aussi de mettre en
place un sur amortissements ça a déjà
été évoquée donc j'ai pas revenir là
dessus de manière trop importante
et puis de restituer le carry back qui
avait été mis en place précédemment
pendant la précédente crise par ailleurs
on se pose des questions sur le sujet du
chômage partiel et des décomptes
repartir le sujet actuellement c'est
d'aider les entreprises est beau sur
beaucoup de dossiers on se rend compte
qu'il y à des contreparties demandées
par l'état alors soit sur l'évolution du
chômage partiel qui est en cours
l'idée c'est de dire il faut absolument
des accords d'entreprise qui permettent
d'augmenter la prise en charge par
l'état et c'est là on dit attention
attention à ne pas trop contraindre
parce que déjà dans les plans de
maintien dans l'emploi ce qu'on avait vu
dans ce qu'ils avaient été votés
précédemment bien avant cette crise y
est bien on s'était rendu compte que les
contraintes qui était mise en place
finalement empêché de signer ce genre de
le contrat de maintien dans l'emploi et
derrière on avait potentiellement plus
justement de faillite
donc le sujet c'est un moment de se
poser la question est ce que vraiment on
peut contraindre autant les entreprises
quand on leur propose de l'aide de
l'autre côté et ça c'est un sujet qui
nous préoccupe parce que on voit
beaucoup beaucoup surgir de ce débat en
ce moment dans le débat public qui est
de dire alors d'accord on aide mais en
contrepartie il doit y avoir d
engagement de maintien de tous les
emplois de pas faire de licenciements
etc
attention c'est pas forcément la bonne
piste et on se rend compte que dans
d'autres pays c'est pas du tout ce qui a
été pour l'instant développé alors autre
sujet bien sûr c'est la reconstruction
c'est ce que tout le monde ici a appelé
le jour d'après et finalement dans le
jour d'après on va avoir les mêmes
problèmes que dans le jour d'avant
c'est à dire une sur fiscalité qui pèse
énormément sur nos entreprises
alors je vais pas revenir là encore sur
énormément de chiffres mais nous avons
montré à la fondation ifrap que nous
avons un écart par rapport aux pays de
la zone euro d'une centaine de milliards
d'euros payés par nos entreprises en
plus en fiscalité
tout confondu un en 2018 on était à 431
milliards d'euros de fiscalité
l'ensemble des prélèvements obligatoires
pesant sur nos entreprises ça représente
18 points 4 points de pub c'est 100
milliards de plus que la moyenne des
pays qui sont dans la zone monétaire
avec nous et là on a une vraie
inquiétude pour les prochaines années
parce que évidemment puisqu'on est plus
ponctionnés sur nos entreprises puisque
finalement la trésorerie souffre plus on
a vu que nos entreprises étaient rentrés
plus endettés dans la crise que leurs
partenaires leur leur entre guillemets
concurrentes et collègues européenne eh
bien on se rend compte des ils ont aussi
pour nos entreprises et en particulier
la fiscalité de production aux cetc soit
environ 70 milliards qui pèsent sur nos
entreprises
qui pèse avant même d'avoir réalisé du
bénéfice qui pèse donc de manière quand
même très lourdes 1 dès que vous ouvrez
votre entreprise vous avez en france des
taxes sur la production que vous
connaissez tous la cvae la cfe l'ifer
l'etac transport etc etc
et là nous avons fait des propositions à
la fondation ifrap avec trois scénarii
différents pour baisser énormément ces
taxes de production en montrant que si
on les baisser de manière à environ une
trentaine de milliards d'euros d'ici
eh bien ça permettait de créer plus de
400000 emplois à l'horizon 2024
alors là on évoque beaucoup de chiffres
en ce moment on sait qu'on va avoir de
la destruction d'emplois
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que ce
sera 500 à 600 mille emplois détruits eu
véritablement d'ici la fin de l'année
donc si on veut recréer de l'emploi en
france pour produire en france derrière
et pour aussi consommer français puisque
c'est un sujet qui ressurgit aussi dans
le débat ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure
par michel edouard leclerc
eh bien il faut le faire avec une
possibilité de produire avec des prix
qui soient pas exorbitant
ça passe par la baisse des taxes sur la
production et là on voit bien selon
toutes les modélisations que nous avons
fait que ça crée de l'emploi marchand de
baisser ce poids des taxes sur la
production
alors nous on propose tout simplement de
baisser énormément la cvae la cfe est
aussi de supprimer la c3s est par
ailleurs en parallèle de cette baisse de
taxes sur la production de baisser
encore les charges et notamment non pas
uniquement sur les bas salaires comme on
a fait toutes ces dernières années et on
a vu à quel point ça permettait de créer
de l'emploi à court terme mais pas à
moyen long terme et que notamment en
parallèle de ces baisses massives de
charges sur les bas salaires
on avait des destructions d'emplois dans
l'industrie notamment 1
donc là il faut se poser la question de
qu'est ce qu'on veut pour demain
est ce qu'on veut des emplois à valdes à
valeur ajoutée avec de la production
industrielle en france ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi baisser les charges sur
les salaires qui sont plus élevés au
delà de 1,6 smic et là on fait une
proposition de baisser dans vie
7 milliards d'euros ses charges pour
booster vraiment la création d'emplois à
forte valeur ajoutée dans les prochaines
années on a vu que la france était
particulièrement fragile dans la crise
parce que nous sommes beaucoup fondée
sur un modèle qui repose sur beaucoup de
ce qu'on appelle des emplois peu
qualifiés des petits boulots notamment
dans le tourisme
voilà c'est pas du tout mauvais d'avoir
un tourisme fort mais néanmoins on voit
que des pays plus industrielles
notamment comme l'allemagne où il ya une
vingtaine de pourcent du pib qui est
industriel et bien l'allemagne rebondi
plus vite patrick martin l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure je vais pas revenir dessus
mais il est évident que les allemands
ont beaucoup moins freiné leur
production
beaucoup d'entreprises avec qui nous
sommes en contact à la fois a été à
quasiment à l'arrêt ou à 20 ou 30% en
france et en allemagne
la même entreprise tournait à 100% au
plein en plein coeur du confinement
il faut bien le dire quand même parce
que ça ça va évidemment mon handicap et
d'une certaine manière pour la reprise
il faut bien en avoir conscience
alors après je voudrais parler aussi de
la question du temps de travail qui a
été une question très très très
débattues ces derniers temps le sujet
c'est pas de faire travailler tout le
monde plus venir mais il faut être
vraiment hyper flexible dans cette
période voilà et la flexibilité qui a
été ton ou lait est au coeur de la crise
en approuvant cette idée de qu'on
pouvait travailler jusqu'à 60 heures par
semaine avec une moyenne de 48 heures
sur 12 semaines etc
mais ça ça va brême bonbons 111
il faut conserver de la flexibilité sur
ce sujet aussi faire en sorte de une
vision du côté des syndicats s'alarment
des entreprises de notre pays et de
cotisations sociales supplémentaires qui
pèsent sur nos entreprises
le pendant
c'est ce tueur radio ou istres as tu un
française on a un système dont on a bien
vu au coeur de la crise sanitaire que
finalement on a qui font que nous sommes
vraiment beaucoup plus cher en termes de
coût de production des services publics
beaucoup plus cher que nos voisins
européens
si vous prenez une vingtaine de pays
devra en reprenant les statistiques ocde
tout 27 % du pib dans les pays
comparables
ça fait un écart de 81,4 milliards
d'euros par an de coûts de production de
nos services publics qui est plus cher
que dans on peut faire un parallèle
entre ce coup de la sueur
administrations françaises et lelas la
surimposition de nos entreprises
là il y a vraiment un sujet très
important
est ce qu'on peut constater c'est que si
on décentralise est vraiment les
missions de cet homme public qui
aujourd'hui de la compétence ou parfois
des départements
eh bien on aurait une possibilité
d'économiser énormément dans les
prochaines années donc baisser les
impôts et enfin dans un second temps
évidemment se poser la question et
xavier ragot l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
chaque euro d'argent public doit être
bien dépensée doit être dépensé avec
efficience et pour qu'il soit dépensé
avec efficience
il faut absolument qu'on se rende compte
que notre surcoût public n'est pas
forcément une n'apporte pas un gain de
qualité de service public on l'a vu dans
la crise nous avons 15 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires sur l'hôpital
public
les allemands par rapport aux allemands
et pourtant ils ont plus de lits de
réanimation que nous pourquoi parce que
c'est décentralisée c'est géré au niveau
du land
parce qu'elle la flexibilité
parce que il ya aussi l'idée de
travailler ensemble entre secteur public
et secteur privé parce que il n'y a pas
de statut la fonction publique
hospitalière en allemagne parce que le
temps de travail n'est pas le même enfin
il ya énormément de choses à dire là
dessus on avait montré une étude de la
fondation ifrap avec le chiffre à 1 42
milliard d'euros de coûts de production
rien que dans la sécurité sociale
pourquoi parce que nos assurances sont
aussi enchâssés avec l'assurance maladie
de base l'assurance complémentaire etc
et donc on peut énormément gagné sur les
coûts de nos services publics et ça il
faut le dire et le redire parce que la
crise nous l'a énormément seigner il ne
faudra pas passer à côté c'est pour ça
que nous proposions de décentraliser à
la fois la gestion de l'école et de la
santé vraiment cette crise a montré
qu'il faut être beaucoup plus local dans
sa gestion
par ailleurs nous avions ago a évoqué la
dette tout à l'heure on va vers les 120
% dette c'est ce qui a été dit hier par
les ministres de bercy 120% dette
c'est quand même assez préoccupant alors
l'idée de dire qu'aujourd'hui la dette
ne serait plus un problème
je crois que c'est pas la dette qu'ovide
qui est un problème ce qui est un
problème c'est la dette d'hier qu'on n'a
pas réussi à faire réduire
sachant que nos amis des pays bas de
l'allemagne ont énormément travaillé sur
ces sujets ces dernières années et il
n'est pas tout à fait exact de digne que
on serait sur les mêmes niveaux
d'endettement que les pays comparables
puisque quand on regarde les pays du
nord de l'europe
on voit que les allemands vont aller
vers 70 % dette et pas vers 120 % de
dette
on voit que les pays bas seront aussi à
peu près dans les mêmes niveaux de
dettes que les allemands donc on a
vraiment une différence entre les pays
qui ont décidé de faire du frein à
l'endettement qui ont décidé en période
de croissance de baisser la dépense de
baisser la dette de réduire les déficits
de faire de l'excédent primaire
ce que nous n'avons pas fait donc quand
on dit que les finances publiques
françaises étaient saines au moment de
rentrer dans la crise non
malheureusement les finis demeurent
finances publiques françaises n'était
pas saine au moment d'entrer dans la
crise
elle était plus tôt
dans une situation déjà préoccupante
avec 50 milliards de déficit structurel
et la difficulté qu'on va avoir dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années eh
bien ça va être une difficulté qui n'est
pas lié à cette crise mais qui est lié à
finalement ce qu'on a empilé en termes
de dette sur les années précédant la
crise est donc là il ya vraiment un
sujet très important je pense pour le
sénat qui est de dire faisons aussi
décidons un frein à l'endettement pour
les prochaines années
non pas pour le mettre en place tout de
suite mais pour qu'il y ait dans la
constitution française
aussi cet outil qui a permis à la fois
aux allemands enfin on l'a bien vu
d'être beaucoup plus fort dans la crise
de proposer un niveau de plan au niveau
budgétaire qui est bien plus important
d'aérer un rapport du sénat qui l'a très
bien montré qui est bien plus important
que celui qu'on a mis en place donc
quand on veut être fort dans la crise il
faut préparer la prochaine crise est ce
que nous on a fait malheureusement en
france c'est qu'on a continué bonnand
mal an qu'on ait de la croissance ou par
a conservé un endettement structurel de
50 milliards d'euros
et ça c'est pas possible de conserver
cette façon de fonctionner pour les
années qui viennent
cette crise doit être un enseignement en
la matière et pour les parlementaires
aussi l'enseignement qu'il faut être
vraiment au chevet de cette dette et la
comprendre comprendre c'est sous jacent
comprendre notamment le fait qu'on va
s'endetter beaucoup à court terme aussi
en envisageant que les charges et impôts
vont être tout enfin que tout va être
payé assez vite alors que en réalité on
sait très bien qu'il va falloir et à
aller plus qu'il va falloir renoncer à
des créances surchargé sur impôts des
entreprises et donc attention attention
à la gestion de cette dette dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années et
disons nous aussi qu'il faut assainir
nos finances publiques pour ne pas nous
retrouver face à une prochaine crise
parce qu'il aura toujours d'autres
crises dans une situation encore plus de
fragilité voilà merci merci beaucoup
avant de donner la parole à mes
collègues je vais peut-être demande à
michel edouard leclerc de réagir ce
qu'il a entendu
après sa propre intervention est
peut-être
lui demander aussi puisqu'on parle de
consommation vous en avez beaucoup parlé
michel ettorre mais aussi
d'investissement le point de vue d'un
distributeur d'un commerçant sur les
investissements qui vont être utiles
obligatoire pour relancer le commerce
durablement
alors j'ai trouvé des beaucoup
d'éléments de consensus dans ce qu'on a
dit et des choses très intelligentes et
je dirais que le projet pts propos de
pas cher mais j'achète le propos de
monsieur ragots parce que je le trouve
extrêmement structurants jeu pour qui
permet il offre un cadre à nous tous de
réinsérer nos observations dans ce qui
est du traitement du court terme aussi
bien la gestion sociale le chômage les
aides aux plus démunis il le gaz ils
organisent une case dette qu'ovide qui
est à prendre avec des qui brûlent
meetic qui est sérieux et ça nous permet
de reposer plus tranquillement et pas
dans l'urgence et peut-être en gérant
mieux les injonctions les futurs agents
qui sont contradictoires
le plan dit de croissance ou un plan
plus ambitieux de notre de la relance de
notre économie ou de la conversion de
notre économie parce que on va pas
relancer forcément à l'identique la
crise c'est aussi une opportunité
pas forcément il suit même des
enseignements de la crise mais c'est une
opportunité dans le temps de rct la
politique d'investissement d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises et notamment
d'accélérer cet engagement qu'on
ressemble tous vers une économie plus
verte une économie plus économes
d'énergie et c'est donc j'achète le plan
de monsieur ragots faudrait que le dise
trop souvent parce qu'il va monter ses
prix mais je trouvais ça très très très
claires donc politique d'offre politique
demande sur la demande
je suis d'accord que le point sur lequel
on doit se concentrer ce sont les
populations les plus démunies les plus
touchées touchés financièrement touché
psychologiquement
qui déjà voyez le train passer et qu'il
a il a raison il faut il faut dans le dé
confinement et le transfert de mesures
il faut y aller très progressivement
sinon on va voir des tensions sociales
extraordinaire il ya des populations à
très faible pouvoir d'achat qui même au
travail se sont vus pour la première
fois de leur vie alors qu'ils étaient
jeunes qualifiés de chômeurs alors il y
avait des avantages financiers grâce aux
aides de l'état le chômage partiel etc
mais quand vous prenez dans les dents
que chef de famille vous êtes chômeur ou
femme au foyer vous êtes chômeur même
partiel ça explique un certain nombre de
soucis de réassurance je dirais
heureusement d'ailleurs qu'on a enterré
le projet des retraites parce que là ça
crée de l'insécurité sur le futur et et
de l'insécurité immédiat sur le secteur
de la consommation donc pour moi la
question qui va venir en injonction
contradictoire avec la compétitivité la
question c'est de faire évoluer les
revenus du travail à la fois pour donner
envie de travailler pour redonner
comparativement envie de travailler par
rapport aux mesures d'assistance et de
est donc dans le débat qu'on a vu il ya
ya quinze jours entre bergers et le
président du medef sur la revalorisation
des bas salaires
je trouve qu'il ya une idée alors je
fais attention à ce que je dis pas ce
que je peux pas allumer la poudre mais
quand même l'état depuis les gilet jaune
assez a pris beaucoup de mesures
d'assistance
on a pallié à on a développé des revenus
de transferts on a toutes choses qui
coûtent énormément mais on n'a pas lâché
on s'est pas penché sur le thème de la
valorisation du travail qui est à la
fois la source de revenus de long terme
qui associe
les personnes au travail et qui au fond
nous a garanti qu'il n'y a pas eu trop
d'absentéisme dans les entreprises les
primes c'est une chose les à côtés c'est
une chose mais ne pas pouvoir grandir et
s'identifier à une qualification un
travail un parcours dans une entreprise
je trouve que ça c'est vraiment un sujet
c'est un sujet tabou
bien sûr chez ali frappe c'est un sujet
tabou
souvent au medef je me rends compte que
j'y vais avec des pincettes mais je
trouve qu'il ya comme quelque chose de
fondamental que cette crise a révélé
et vous voyez par exemple je suis un
militant de la participation et de
l'intéressement les centres leclerc dont
25% du bénéfice devrait donner 25 % du
bénéfice avant impôts se forme
d'intéressement de participation et
gratifications
mais quand on aborde ce sujet évidemment
il faut encore qui est de la ressource à
distribuer et si on laborde au moment où
il n'y a pas d'argent à donner c'est
juste une idée c'est pas tangibles donc
pour moi c'est une vrai sujet que de
cette généralisation des accords
d'intéressement et de participation
d'associations capital travail que je
fais partie de la génération et laitière
décapitant wallon et est de cette
génération de gaulliste qui avait
travaillé sur ce sujet c'est un vrai
sujet qu'il faut aujourd'hui travailler
la revalorisation des bas salaires je
pense que ça c'est nécessaire après les
transferts de l' épargne actuelle mais
en italie c'est pareil aussi vers la
consommation ouvert du financement de
l'investissement
effectivement ça suppose là pour le
consommateur pour les salariés pour les
travailleurs une confiance retrouvée
dans un futur quoi si on nous dira où le
dossier des retraites je peux vous dire
que les pages de la garde
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
sur le plan des investissements je suis
impressionné que en macroéconomie on
manie les chiffres et les équations en
comptabilité mais pas en textures je
veux dire si
vous me donnez aujourd'hui 100 milliards
moi je sais pas quoi en faire
je pense qu'il faudrait inverser la
problématique
il faut avoir d'abord l'ambition et
après on va chercher les moyens on voit
bien aujourd'hui que parmi les facteurs
de relance le secteur hospitalier
aujourd'hui la médecine la santé de
patrick artus jacques attali ça ils
n'ont pas arrêté il ya des centaines
d'économistes qui n'arrête pas de dire
que c'est le vecteur demain d'une
croissance d'une demande considérable
dans une population vieillissante et il
faut pas regarder que le marché franc
que l'attractivité du marché français
hexagonal il faut regarder l'ensemble on
a là un secteur sur lequel il faut
investir massivement
ce qui va poser des problèmes de
définition tarifaire et de sortir des
idéologies mais c'est un secteur sur
lequel évidemment on pourrait investir
massivement
parce que ça correspond à un vrai besoin
sur le transport sur le secteur de la
mobilité et des transports
au delà des des sous secteurs voiture
avion etc
on connaît on a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers temps des besoins moi je
voudrais rappeler qu' il y a c'est très
concret il ya 25 ans j'ai fait raccordé
jeune président des centres leclerc j'ai
fait raccorder tous les entrepôts
leclerc à la sncf
aujourd'hui il ya du gazon partout sur
les sur les voies c'est à dire que y'a
jamais eu alors que c'est un dans
l'intérêt de l'écologie dans l'intérêt
d'une économie il ya jamais eu une
volonté sur le long terme de s'affronter
peut-être au lobby des camionneurs mais
d'une manière générale il ya tout le
transport des marchandises
aujourd'hui à organiser de manière plus
verte plus économes d'énergie mais qui
est un véritable secteur comme le 10ème
sur ago sur lequel il faut il faut
investir sur le secteur du tourisme
on a un peu épuisé la bête
on a aujourd'hui des fortes
concentrations dans des zones
touristiques avec des endroits
magnifiques qui vont accueillir des
milliards de chinois d'indiens etc
mais il ya aussi c'est aussi un secteur
alors à financer évidemment par le
secteur privé qui en est un des
principes aux opérateurs mais l'état
introduisant à la contrainte écologique
je peux participer à cette évolution
on est des gisements en hâter gisement
de consommation et on a des gisements
d'investissement qui sont considérables
donc moi dans le cadre de ce qui est le
jour d'après et le jour d'avant le jour
d'avant
le jour 2 juste après je pense qu'il
faut s'occuper des faillites des aspects
de trésorerie des allègements de charge
et ne pas mélanger ça avec le l'économie
française de 2035 qui nécessite la non
pas des dépenses mais des
investissements sur le futur et qu'on
peut financer effectivement par la dette
on va pas recommencer quand je relisais
encore et la semaine dernière le coup
qu'on a fait aux grecs qu'on a mis à
genoux pour des histoires de principe
et quand on voit aujourd'hui que on joue
avec la dette comme si elles étaient
illimitées ne retombons pas dans leur
nière de l'analyse comptable et
commençons par travailler sur les
projets d'investissement merci merci
michel et bat patrick martin je voulais
vous et provoqué un petit peu à la fin
de votre intervention tout à l'heure en
parlant des injonctions contradictoires
il en est une qui nous est chère au
sénat c'est le discours de attention
collectivités territoriales puisqu'elle
représente 70 % les investissements en
france et en même temps supprimons ou
diminuant les impôts de production
auront sections soit une source d'
investissement enfin sont une source de
recettes
précisément pour les collectivités
territoriales comment est ce que vous
envisagez ce cette injonction
contradictoire à lasbordes si vous me
permettez je dois vous dire que le bds
n'a pas renoncé à son souci d'orthodoxie
des finances publiques
mais enfin convenez que nous sommes dans
une situation tout à fait exceptionnelle
il faut quand même bien prendre
contre le fait que c'est un fait sans
précédent dans l'histoire y compris en
période de guerre c'est l'état ce sont
les états eux mêmes qui ont mis
l'économie à l'arrêt et plus en france
mais partout ailleurs
quand on dit l'état moi je ne perds
jamais de vue que derrière l'état il ya
des citoyens avec contribuable donc que
la collectivité assume y compris
financièrement les décisions qui ont été
prises par l'état lui-même ça me paraît
pas choquant et puis on est en situation
d'urgence
donc le pragmatisme le principe de
réalité doivent doivent l'emporter
ça ne m'empêche pas de partager en tout
point ce qu agnès verde ball idéal il ya
un véritable problème déficience de la
dépense publique est elle si cette chose
malheur est bon si cette circonstance
exceptionnelle que nous vivons peut nous
amener à poser à dire fondamental ce
sujet de l'efficience de la dépense
publique bien tant mieux
un saisissant de s'agissant de en fait
de l'assiette et de la destination des
impôts de production on tourne en rond
ça n'est pas nouveau non tournent de
plus en plus vite parce que là aussi les
circonstances précipite j'ai un certain
nombre de débats sur qui doit payer qui
doit encaisser
on écoute a évidemment beaucoup
d'intérêt des propos de bono le maire
qui répétitivement j'ai déjà plus encore
qu'avant la crise ducobu nous disent
qu'on a envie d'entendre depuis des
années à savoir que ses impôts de
production sont un contresens économique
et social et sociales sur les salaires
facilement mais on entend tout autant
les associations d'élus locaux qui nous
disent oui mais enfin il n'y a pas de
raison sur les collectivités locales
au delà de ce que l'état pourra et devra
d'ailleurs lâché noti2 il n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit les collectivités
locales effectivement les plus beaux
investisseur public qui soit la variable
d'ajustement
ça c'est un sujet de tuyauterie entre
les collectivités publiques
notre dimension territoriale la mienne
singulièrement elle est extrêmement
forte
c'est l'occasion pour moi de dire que ça
serait quand même paradoxal mais le
risque existe que le même état
qui qui a arrêté l'économie qui à
certains égards a démontré certaines
faiblesses veille
administré de a à z l'économie française
comme il est parti pour le faire des
protocoles de confinement quand vous
regardez ce qui le discours public qu'on
nous entende et le discours public
nous sauvons les emplois nous serons les
entreprises oui c'est bien moi l'état et
un bleu
l'assureur de dernier ressort mais on
voit on voit pointer chez certains à la
fois pardon d'être très directe dans mon
propos à la fois dans la fonction
publique qui par nature et étatiste mais
également dans certaines écoles de
pensée ce cette idée que de toute façon
il faut que tout soit collectiviser
alors pas au sens marxiste du terme et
le sens étatiste la même chose quand
même bien nous pensions que ce serait
extrêmement dans l'autre c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire que nous
soutiendrons et nous essaierons de
contribuer d'ailleurs à l'amélioration
du projet de loi 3d parce que ça nous
paraît à l'épreuve de cette crise
d'autant plus urgence de renvoyer
finalement du pouvoir de décision et du
pouvoir d'action aux acteurs les plus
proches du terrain ça peut être les
collectivités locales
ça peut être ça doit être les
entreprises si demain au motif qu'il
faut transformer les pg en fonds propres
et quasi fonds propres
on a un actionnaire détenant des tpe et
des pme
je mets ma main à couper que ça ne
contribuera pas beaucoup à la prospérité
du pays
on rentrera dans des modes de
fonctionnement totalement administrées
lourd incompétent en la matière l'état
voilà venir directement à votre question
le sujet c'est que l'état prenne à sa
charge
on compense d'une certaine manière tu
avec une bonne visibilité je dirais pour
l'avenir ce que les collectivités
locales perdrait sous forme de
production ads l'a dit et redit
disons que c'est un vrai boulot et ça va
devenir un boulet
insurmontable si on peut dire dans le
cadre de la nécessaire prise
merci monsieur a beau vous nous proposez
de m à part la dette qu'ovide n'ont fait
quoi de cette dette
comment la gère à part comment l'art en
bourse
je vais vous dire mais auparavant je
voudrais réagir sur un point pour un
essayer de deux mois me cacher derrière
les chiffres est premièrement j'ai
commencé par dire comme je crois à la
consommation responsable et qu'il faut
avoir des signes politiques dans sa
consommation
les prochaines courses que j'irais faire
j'irai faire dans un magasin leclerc
parce que ce que j'ai entendus me séduit
assez je vais commencer sur l'allemagne
pour dire quelque chose dont on n'a pas
parlé qu'elle est essentielle
je peux parler de passion de la dette
allemande la dette allemande c'était 80
% du pib en 2010 comme la france
pourquoi la dette allemande et 60% du
crime ont dit ils peuvent faire
aujourd'hui grâce à une dette faible
pourquoi on dit parce qu'ils ont 20 % de
base industrielle pourquoi ils ont un
pourcentage des tas de base industrielle
je pourrais multiplier les exemples
qu'est ce qu'elle est la singularité
allemande par rapport à la france
on peut rentrer dans tous les détails la
réalité c'est qu'il ya un peu moins
d'état pourquoi il ya moins d'états
parce que ça se passe dans l'entreprise
le truc centrales en allemagne c'est la
qualité du dialogue social d'entreprise
on peut tourner autour du pot la
création de valeur en contrepartie c'est
l'entreprise c'est la participation des
acteurs
le grand sujet pour moi et je parle en
mon nom propre la d 10 15 ans qui
viennent c'est la question du dialogue
social d'entreprise regarder l'attitude
des syndicats nous ce que les tendances
à dire haut patronage mon sqc qu'on a
les syndicats qu'on mérite c'est un peu
facile et l'excusé moyens on a un
problème du dialogue social comment
réinvestir les aides sociales
sage pour moi je peux vous multipliez
les bases sociales et c'est à être ça la
question centrale l'après crise c'est
comment faire est-ce que participation
intéressement ça suffit est ce qu'il
faut aller dans un modèle de cogestion
vous savez il ya deux salariés
administrateurs salariés des entreprises
de plus de 5000
c'est noël 2013 s'est passé c'est cette
question-là de la réactivation du
dialogue social
c'est ça qui nous permettra de
d'intégrer les questions sanitaires ce
que c'est vrai que l'entreprise
allemande ont mieux résisté à la
fermeture des entreprises françaises
c'est vrai qu'il ya moins de
juridicisation du confit social
mais là quelle est la cause en serait la
cause c'est la construction la
reconstruction d'après guerre allemande
qui a construit ce modèle de cogestion
qu'inefficace était redoutable au niveau
international c'est un petit coin aussi
choqués que vous insistez le pays le
plus puissant du monde
c'est l'allemagne c'est notre voisin on
se compare l'allemagne mais on peut se
comparer aux états unis on peut se
comparer à d'autres pays qui vont
beaucoup moins bien que nous d'être sur
pivot aux etats unis c'est à grand chose
le pays qui sort le plus fort que modèle
économique d'intégration sociale et
politique cette allemagne
au niveau international on croit que
c'est france allemagne deux pays qui ont
ils restent encore garde l'intégrité du
monde
on voit qu'il ya les spécificités du
modèle allemand et on peut apprendre en
investissant dans dans le dialogue
social et beaucoup de mesures que je
kiffe envisagée sera ça c'est
l'appropriation sanitaire inégalités
donc valorisation du travail et
environnementales au niveau des
entreprises et pourquoi en état aussi
fort en france et ainsi forcer
l'assureur en dernier ressort quand
dialogue social a échoué c'est pour ça
que l'état et devient la cyber ans ça
marche au niveau entreprise résiduelles
mansle et après décision parce que
beaucoup d'acteurs renvoi d sion détail
après critique parce que tu as fait trop
il faut je pense investir le paritarisme
certains de mes collègues veulent faire
le deuil du paritarisme mme français il
ya un option affaire qui investirent le
paritarisme c'est une grande option
français de l'après crise séméga et les
membres sont mon avis plutôt personnelle
j'ai pas de données scientifiques pour
le chiffre est donc
excusez moi je c'était un élément
d'environnement petit 2 sur les impôts
de production je pense qu'un accord
assez général
effectivement ce qu'a dit à patrick
injuste et cueillir une question de
financement des collectivités locales
tout résoudre pour arriver et qui est
une question importante politique sur
lequel il faut trancher mais ya une
sorte de consensus de beaucoup d'acteurs
d'économistes notamment on avait je suis
au conseil d'analysé économique auprès
du premier ministre on again note qui a
été fait les impôts contre
l'introduction qu'on va dire
qu'effectivement il ya consensus
la question d'après sait comment finance
comment finances et et personnellement
dans ces instances là on a une
une doctrine c'est quand on augmente les
dépenses publiques faut à chaque fois
dire comment le finance parce que c'est
un petit peu facile de baisser les
impôts de tout le monde
de vouloir contrôler la dette et pas
dire on trouve l'argent et on voit que
quand on a fait ça le pays a explosé ça
a amené à 2013 on a fait une hausse de
2% et d'autres prélèvements obligatoires
hyper mal fait ça donne les pigeons et
le pays on a mis deux pays à l'arrêt il
fonde l'acceptabilité sociale de l'impôt
c'est la question cruciale aujourd'hui
dans l'après crise aussi il faut
l'intégrer toutes ses dimensions là haut
niveau d' équilibre entre d'entreprise
les ménages sculptures de ménage et
autres parler maintenant de fiscalité en
termes de grandes masses sans parler de
l'acceptabilité sociale de l'impôt vous
savez ce que ça va donner on l'a eu des
gériatres il faut qu on politise la
question fiscale
c'est essentiel c'est en tant
qu'économie je le pense pour la question
de l'acceptabilité de l'impôt justifier
la structure fiscalité je pense les
après la production ça se justifie pour
des questions économiques parce que et
des questions sociales et questions
d'emploi pour ma part si on m'avait
demandé mon point de vue j'aurais dit
qu'il faut financer la baisse des impôts
la production par une baisse un peu
moindre de liesse dans un premier temps
donc assiette fiscale globale optimisée
à cette fiscales ces entreprises je
pense qu'il y avait un consensus qui
d'émerger une fois qu'on a fait cette
émotion fiscal c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué trouver de l'argent mais je
pense que module autour de l'argent nerf
intelligent je pense qu'il ya un
consensus qui peut émerger sur les
impôts de production parce que c'est
effectivement une fiscalité qui est pas
très intelligente en france et qui on a
évolué pour des questions de blocage
politique et un petit peu budgétaire
voilà je je m'arrête là soit d'être co
vite me répond madame la présidente
quand même parce que sais je
c'était qu'une introduction pour votre
réponse bah regardé comme on a géré la
calèche c'était pas bête
on a géré la dette sociale on a créé un
impôt qui est pas bête alors désolé il
ya un moment il faut payer
il faudra payer les intérêts cette dette
la bonne nouvelle c'est que l'intérêt
sera très très faibles voire négatifs
donc si un horizon de laisse de lissage
très très très long les charges
d'intérêts annuelles sont très faibles
faut en avoir conscience à le coût de sa
dette sera très faible aujourd'hui c'est
le nouveau monde le taux d'intérêt sont
négatifs sur l'endettement à aller
tonnes long terme à dix ans de
de grands pays comme signature forte
dont la france donc il va nous coûter
très très peu cher sa tête
donc il faut la lisser dans le temps et
définir un impôt haddock qui sera très
faible et donc il faut qu'ils aient
l'assiette sociale la plus large et qui
le bon un coût historiquement k pearl
dirait la can s était à ses yeux c'est
une assiette large du rhône du
patrimoine du revenu de répartition du
travail une assiette à plus large
possible pour avoir le taux le plus bas
possible en expliquant qu' un argot de
reconstruction c'est exactement la façon
dont les allemands vont gérer la
reconstruction après la réunification
allemande
ils ont eu un un coq de transfert à
l'est basé sur une solide et à nationale
faible qui a permis de construction et
avait complètement accepté parce qu'il y
avait une visibilité politique de
l'impôt là je pense la même chose votre
visibilité politique une csg guide très
bien merci je vais peut-être juste à
vous passer la parole à mes collègues
fait réagir
agnès l'indemnité sur cette proposition
de monde d'impôt si je comprends bien un
impôt de reconstruction pour pour
rembourser même à long terme la dette
alors j'ai plusieurs petites choses à
dire avant sur l'allemagne
je ne crois pas que la faible dette
allemande soit liée simplement à un
meilleur dialogue social dans les
entreprises allemandes qui est un
meilleur dialogue social c'est en fait
eu d'accord avec xavier ragot là dessus
chez nos amis allemands
mais ce meilleur dialogue social est
aussi issu des modalités de financement
des syndicats
nos syndicats de salariés sont
énormément financer aussi une bille en
malheureuse magne la cgt demander
l'arrêt des lignes de production demandé
la fermeture d'usinés qu'il considérait
comme non les 106 et madame verdier
molinié est ce que leur dit munich est
pardon pardon évidemment et on n'a pas
le même dialogue social aussi en hardox
au québec des syndicats qui sont en
permanence
au plus deux des plus y couper
est ce que je peux vous demander de
malgré le plaisir qu'elle note de
retirer l'image parce qu'on a une très
mauvaise connexion avec votre votre
votre site l'endroit où vous êtes donc
vous êtes vous entend à peine donc
peut-être en retirant la nage allez-y je
pense que la seconde
oui c'est mieux voilà d'accord donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que le dialogue
social en allemagne est effectivement
mais ils sont beaucoup plus financé par
des deniers publics et parce que nos
syndicats sont toujours plus axé sur
plus de dépenses publiques plus d'impôts
est donc là si on veut changer dialogue
social en france il va falloir aussi
changer les habitudes de nos syndicats
et leur positionnement jo vu la cgt
faire un appel à la grève en avril dans
les services publics demander l'arrêt de
lignes de production dans des secteurs
qui considérait comme non essentiels
alors qu'il était essentiel
donc attention les allemands aussi moins
de dette pourquoi tout simplement parce
que ils ont aussi repoussé l'âge de
départ à la retraite ils sont sur un âge
de départ à la retraite de 67 ans
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont mis en
place ce système de frein à
l'endettement
parce qu'ils ont équilibrer leurs
comptes publics en évaluant chaque euro
d'argent public dépensés et avec un
parlement qui est très très très
mobilisé aussi sur ce sujet par ailleurs
sur ce que vous avez dit sur les impôts
de production tout à l'heure c'est à
dire comment on fait pour financer en
ayant des collectivités locales qui
perdent de la recette et finalement des
impôts de prod qui baissent de manière
très positive pour les entreprises mais
moins de recettes pour les collectivités
il faut passer sur l'idée de taxer les
bénéfices et non pas la production ça
veut dire qu'il faudra une part nièce
pour les collectivités et j'en avais
déjà parlé avec beaucoup d'élus de
collectivités en leur disant maintenant
il faut arrêter de voir fac c'est la
preuve pour vos territoires pour
finalement que nos entreprises soient
dans vos territoires plus puissante
qu'elle se développe mieux et bien il
faut accepter de taxer au niveau du
bénéfice
ce que m'avait répondu les élus locaux à
l'époque c'est que il y avait de leur
part plutôt une propension à se dire que
c'était plus facile de taxer la
production que de taxer les bénéfices
parce qu'il n'était pas sûr que les
entreprises en question fassent des
bénéfices nokla ya aussi une question de
confiance entre les élus locaux et leur
tissu entrepreunarial qu'il faut recréer
parce que c'est c'est trop facile de
vouloir augmenter les taxes sur la
production comme on l'a vu ces dernières
années
et à chaque fois que il ya eu des
baisses de charge de l'autre côté il ya
eu des augmentations de taxes sur la
prod souvent au niveau des collectivités
locales ce qui a fait que la fiscalité
sur nos entreprises n'a pas baissé entre
2012 et 2018 en part de pib sur la dette
la dette la mauvaise dette et la bonne
dette 1 c il ya un vrai sujet en france
là dessus c'est à dire qu'on nous dit
toujours
finalement pour investir il faut
s'endetter mais on s'endette en
permanence pour financer le
fonctionnement de nos administrations
si on ne sent d'été que pour investir je
peux vous dire qu'on aurait une dette
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus faible
donc prenons au mot ne nous endettons
que pour investir et là on va faire
mécaniquement évidemment baisser la
dette française là il ya un vrai
problème sur la différenciation entre ce
qui est un réel investissement et ce
qu'est finalement une dépense de
fonctionnement à chaque fois qu'on a une
crise on nous promet énormément de plans
d'avenir de plans d'investissement qui
se transforme aussi en des plans de
dépenses de fonctionnement et ça c'est
un homme un vrai un vrai sujet sur la
dette qu'ovide vous me posez la question
évidemment nous avons proposé la
fondation ifrap de s'endetter sur la
plus longue durée possible dans cette
période c'est à dire sur 50 ans sur 80
ans voire sur plus pourquoi parce que ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'actuellement on
emprunte aussi beaucoup pour la moitié
des besoins supplémentaires en
endettement est bien ce qui est prévu de
faire c'est que la moitié ce seront des
enfants
à court terme et donc ça nous pose souci
si on veut véritablement faire en sorte
d'étaler cette dette et ne pas se
retrouver dans un mur de la dette en
2023 parce qu'en 2023 on a énormément de
dette publique qui arrive un peu à
échéance et qu'on va devoir refinancer
et bien là nous avons vraiment un sujet
sur l'idée de l'emprunter sur le plus
long terme possible même si l'auto est
un peu plus élevée actuellement c'est
beaucoup plus sécurisé pour notre avenir
commun bien sûr sur l'idée de créer des
impôts spécifiques
moi je ne suis pas pour et je trouve
qu'on confond trop dans ce débat des
dépenses publiques et de la fiscalité
ce n'est pas la même chose je suis
désolé dépenses publiques baisser la
dépense publique cbc des dépenses de
l'état des administrations et baisser
les impôts c'est autre chose on est le
pays le plus imposé demander des baisses
d'impôts au sortir d'une crise comme
celle là où en pleine crise puisqu'on y
est toujours mais n'est pas du tout
incohérent au contraire ça prépare
l'avenir et ça nous permet de rebondir
augmenté des dépenses sociales en ce
moment pour permettre plus de
consommation
ça paraît facile le problème c'est qu'on
est déjà à 34 % de dépenses sociales et
qu'on est déjà le pays qui dépense le
plus haut niveau social donc il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut choisir on a
toujours fait ça augmenter les dépenses
sociales et on a toujours pensé qu'on
allait pas liée aux problèmes de notre
économie en faisant gonfler ce système
un peu de la sécurité sociale qu'on a
qu'on a aujourd'hui hypertrophié donc là
la question c'est peut-être justement
sortir de ce système qu'on a mis en
place et je crois qu'il faut absolument
souligner que si on veut se construire
un avenir commun il y à un sujet qui a
été évoqué et c'est là la question de la
réforme des retraites la réforme des
retraites qu'elle telle qu'elle était
envisagée était trop compliqué c'est sûr
elle n'avait pas l'adhésion des français
maintenant repoussé l'âge de la retraite
ce sera absolument une nécessité si on
ne veut pas être obligé d'augmenter les
impôts dans les prochaines années
donc voilà ce que les pays qui ont tenu
dans la crise le mieux au niveau des
finances publiques
c'est ce qui suffit d'aller interroger
d'interroger les hollandais d'interroger
les allemands ils vous expliqueront que
ils ont
les efforts qu'ils travaillent plus
longtemps qu'ils travaillent plus qu'ils
évaluent leurs dépenses qu'ils
consacrent toute leur énergie à évaluer
si chaque mesure chaque loi votée va
créer de l'emploi on va en détruire et
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui qui
est important il faut s'inspirer de ce
qu'ont fait les pays qui sont nos
voisins qui sonne aux partenaires plutôt
que de continuer à rester dans cette
ornière française où on imagine des
aides sociales qui finalement se
surajoute et qui ne permettent pas de
sortir des problèmes très bien merci
alors je vais passer la parole à mes
collègues je vais leur demander mais
vraiment d'être très très court dans
leurs questions parce que vous êtes
assez nombreux mes chers collègues et je
vais faire un tunnel de questions je
m'en excuse pour nos interlocuteurs
je remercie mes collègues de cibler
leurs questions nous allons commencer
par la présidente de la délégation
d'entreprises elisabeth lamure mais
ensuite alain chatillon qui est à mes
côtés
exablate merci beaucoup
madame la présidente d'avoir organisé
ces tables rondes et merci à nos quatre
invités qui ont développé largement leur
sujet et qui ont permis d'ailleurs de
répondre je crois à beaucoup de
questions avec des propositions
il me semble très intéressante je
souhaitais les interrogé notamment sur
les pieux sur le cash de l'epargne ça a
été largement abordée peut-être
m'adresser au président martin sur la
question des relocalisations sur
localisation que nous appelons vraiment
tous de nous re
nous savons que le produire en france
coûtent plus chers qu'à l'étranger et
même en relocalisant des chaînes de
valeur en particulier dans les secteurs
peu automatisable écouteurs en main
d'oeuvre comment faire accepter cette
question du prix donc de la cherté du
made in france au consommateur sans pour
autant entraîner une baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat
et est ce que les baisses de charges ou
la baisse des impôts de production comme
l'a abordée
tout à l'heure l'un ou l'autre d'entre
vous mais plusieurs d'entre vous est ce
que cela suffira
et puis par ailleurs cette
relocalisation notamment industrielles
suppose une grande disponibilité de main
d'oeuvre qualifiée
donc dans le contexte de crise que nous
connaissons actuellement est ce que vous
pensez possible de former rapidement et
massivement cette main d'oeuvre
vous avez proposé aux entreprises
n'embauchent de jeunes en cdi est
également d'apprentis qui est ce que
cela va permettre de créer des
conditions d'emploi durable au delà des
effets d'aubaine qui sont parfois
constatée et puis une société générale
qui concerne la décentralisation vous
pensent en effet qu'une relance
dynamique passe par les la
décentralisation
ce sujet a été abordé d'ailleurs par le
président larcher
ce matin lors de son interview elle nous
avions auditionné il ya peu de temps le
président de l'as tu d'entreprise
messieurs frérot que lui faisait une
proposition assez assez pragmatique à
savoir de consolider les missions des
actuelles comité de conciliation pour en
faire tout simplement des comités de
relance territoriales est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une bonne piste à
suivre
je vous remercie merci elizabeth parole
à alain chatillon et ensuite un roulant
pour toi qui peux comment serait-ce de
préparer à lallaing à toutes et à tous
et merci pour toutes ces informations
ils sont partis comme intéressante
moment où le président
avec épée dans notre dos à l'envers des
premiers rapports oraux j'espère
apportera satisfaction à tous les chefs
d'entreprise et tous ceux qui viennent
voter
première question pour moi c'est ou
donna de la réimplantation d'entreprise
ou d'art ou localisation
ça va être la défense d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises existants qui
devait partir à l'étranger et pour ce
faire il faut des prêts à long terme
avec des théories des taux de retour sur
investissement faible sur une longue
distance
je pense à des secteurs tels permis bus
des pumas et romantique mais aussi
locaux secteur de l'agroalimentaire et
de l'industrie en général
le deuxième point c'est on n'a pas
évoqué le problème de la concurrence qui
vient qui rentre chez nous en france
pense à l'agro alimentaire
particulièrement et alors que les doigts
de la dgccrf
ps le plus souvent muet sur les
questions que vous vous posez
je pense que notre pays a besoin d'être
mieux défendus mieux sécurisés que les
produits rendent bien entendu de leurs
autres soit plus proactive à ce niveau
là que nous ayons les mêmes
réglementations mais que en même temps
ceux qui veulent rentrer se conforment
aux règles de la france ce qui n'est pas
le fait souvent le cas en ce moment là
je m'arrête là je dirai simplement
dernier point que l'agriculture a besoin
de notre appui 8
j'espère que michel edouard saura être
convaincu par le fait que nos
agriculteurs français besoin de
travailler ont besoin de valeur ajoutée
l'opposition refusé pour une charge et
on espère aussi que la distribution est
en pleine révolution et mouhcine on n'a
pas la proximité sera d accompagner
merci oui merci beaucoup je veux jours
il a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs nécessité de soutenir la
consommation des bas revenus de viread
et par milla est évoqué le chef déco
chèque pour les bas revenus
un autre intervenant a parlé de rassurer
les ménages de restaurer la confiance et
plus récemment le libéral financial
times affirmait dans son éditorial
collectif je cite les petits considéré
jusqu'à il ya peu comme excentrique
thème le feu venait de base devront
maintenant c'est à dire avec la crise
sanitaire faire partie du mix des
mesures à prendre pour amortir les chocs
économiques pour protéger les plus
vulnérables pour relancer l'économie
quand on sortira de la crise en fait je
constate alors que la pandémie a
paralysé les colons ni que la question
du revenu universel fait son retour dans
le
emma public et tout certains économistes
ce revenu de base universel serait
temporaire pour d'autres ils devaient
être permanents et prendre la forme
d'une augmentation temporaire de revenu
de base qui lui serait permanent et
certains économistes le disent aussi que
les outils tels que la baisse des taux
d'intérêt pour encourager et les crédits
aux ménages et aux entreprises auraient
atteints totalement leurs limites
d'où cette proposition qui veut bien
dodues revenu de base universel qui
permettrait selon eux l'augmentation de
la consommation et ferait ainsi démarrer
l'économie alors il ya déjà des prémices
au canada il ya des prémices au japon il
y en a à l'espagne et la basse et
mentalement
merci pardon rôles entre qu'ils
voulaient si vous voulez tu voulais que
tu voulais cette question pour qui
précisément pour quel interlocuteur nous
attend pour monsieur leclerc un lecteur
par michèle torr leclerc ok très bien
napa valley donc un très bien ensuite
dans le rang du plan merci madame merci
d'abord parce que moi j'avais un petit
doute sur le monde d'après l'expression
n'utilise pas trop mais au ce matin je
suis rassuré
je pense que le mandat priverait comme
le manque d'allant gêné toutes les
bonnes mesures libérales aux questions
de la fonction publique est bon c'est un
vrai débat et il ya une petite
contradiction qui est soulevée pour prix
et je sais que par exemple qu'elle n'est
pas dans le denek ce parce que j'ai bien
joué quarante propositions et notamment
dans la page 25
toute la partie sur la relance il
soutient la consommation s'est pas
occupé les agissements
donc il ya des choses qui ont bougé dans
cette poule dans cette crise mais quand
même la question qui dit
bien c'est que vous arrêter au milieu du
gué il me semble par exemple sur le
partage de la valeur
c'est à dire le partage de la richesse
créée le partage de la richesse créée se
pose avec force il se posait d'ailleurs
bien avant je sais que vous aviez des
débats au sénat sur cette question y
compris au moment des faits les jeunes
et je pense que vous avez raté ce moment
là de dire ses arguments il faut
augmenter les salaires
je pense que la question des pauses et
d'augmenter les salaires y compris des
petits salaires et ça vient aussi une
question à monsieur leclerc
évidemment il nous parle de la grande
distribution et des questions avec et
sont donc est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est le moment d'augmenter
à quel niveau pensez qu'il faut
augmenter parce que si on reste dans un
choc de l'or je crois qu on ne relancera
pas l'économie est juste me permets de
réflexion moi je suis pour que l'été
chez eux à 100% j'étais d'accord avec
madame sur ce point agnès
verdier-molinié je pense que nous avons
besoin de nos entreprises
mais il ya quand même une contradiction
dans vos propos ce à dire que vous
appelez toujours à moins d'état moins
internations et en même temps quand il
ya des moments de crise à ce que l'état
soutiennent massivement les entreprises
alors là vous allez dire c'est l'état
qui est qui a arrêté l'économie mais
c'était réussi en 2008 lorsqu'une crise
financière la bulle a éclaté
là aussi vous aviez fait appel aux
étables aussi une contradiction est
juste fini j'ai lu une interview de paul
repéré ce matin le célèbre restaurateur
de chandelles qui disait que
contrairement à la france où les
restaurateurs avaient été ré à shanghai
en chine il n'avait pas été est né et il
y avait beaucoup de fermetures
aujourd'hui en termes de reprise et je
pense qu'ils ne ne faut pas oublier ça
aujourd'hui ce que vous appelez charges
qui sont en réalité des cotisations et
des impôts nous permettre de financer ce
modèle social nous permettent
aujourd'hui d'abonder les faux et ce
modèle social aujourd'hui une permet
quand même une protection globale
voilà je vous remercie et revenir si
fabien merci fabien laurent duc l'ont
ensuite franck mesnel ville oui merci
madame
il hante moi je voudrais intervenir pour
dire que je pensais que cette crise
puisse être un électrochoc et je me
rends compte qu au contraire cette crise
va continuer de faire exactement les
mêmes erreurs par le passé
le premier point c'est que nous avons
une des deux de 1350 milliards avant la
crise et nous allons prendre entre 350
et 400 milliards de plus de l'être quand
je vois aujourd'hui par exemple que sur
les 7 milliards de cotisations sociales
qui servent à payer les 6 milliards
retraite et bien le mois dernier nous
avons eu que 3 6 milliards de recettes
ce qui fait que nous n'avons pas les
moyens de payer les retraites de nos
retraités à la fin du mois ce que je
voudrais dire aussi c'est qu'avec plus
de 2500 2700 milliards
à chaque point de taux d'intérêt
supplémentaire
nous allons prendre en montant
d'intérêts près de 21 milliards
supplémentaires alors nous devrions
faire une sacrée hier pour que les taux
d'intérêt restent bas voire négatif
parce que sinon ça va nous poser
d'énormes problèmes le problème de cette
dette
c'est que tout simplement on a fait
prendre conscience aux français que la
dette n'était pas un problème depuis 30
ans alors dit qu'elle peut et qu'elle
peut augmenter sans problème pendant des
années on leur expliquait qu'il fallait
faire des économies et comme par
enchantement du jour au lendemain on a
ouvert les vannes et on a lâché la
totalité de la dette et on explique sur
à la télé par les ministres que la bête
n'est pas un problème
le deuxième élément c'est le nombre de
fonctionnaires en 1980 il y avait 3
millions à kin wah laurent rapidement
aujourd'hui 2 millions de fonctionnaires
le coût de la masse salariale de l'état
ces 154 milliards d'euros ce que je vois
aujourd'hui sur le terrain c'est que le
nombre de fonctionnaires a plutôt
tendance à contraindre les les
investissements à limiter l'esprit
d'entreprise plutôt qu'elle favorisait
le troisième élément et j'en termine là
dessus c'est les paradoxes de notre
société
relancer la consommation ça veut dire
acheter encore plus à l'étranger parce
que ce que nous regardons pas en avant
c'est la compétitivité de nos
entreprises par la problématique de la
peau et surtout pour la problématique
des normes et du fait qu'en france on en
rajoute tout le temps alors je vous le
dis
le message ne devrait être pas plus
claire et plus courageux ne devrions pas
se poser des questions sur le
pragmatisme et de bon sens et la
décentralisation au plus près du local
prend des décisions ne pouvons pas nous
poser la question de redonner du sens de
redonner du sens au travail mérite et
surtout de faire comme l'a dit madame
agnès c'est la relance par
l'investissement devrait être le seul la
seule dépense possible de l'état parce
que c'est grâce à l'investissement que
nous pouvons retrouver des éléments de
compétitivité et des aînés de production
merci laurent malet mme verdier molinié
pas madame agnès c'est pas voilà franck
mais nos villas et ensuite je passe la
parole à joël labbé anc mais nos villes
ton micro peut-être voilà c'est bon là
où l'on qualifie qu on entend la musique
bonjour la cie madame la présidente donc
saluer les quatre intervenants et la
mercier j'ai une petite question
concernant le manadier levin et
notamment partage son analyse en matière
de fiscalité et notamment des infos
concernant les impôts production fossile
aussi des ressources fiscales et elle
est votre votre avis sur une fiscalité
et comment moderniser la fiscalité
davantage capter l'activité et notamment
des plateformes numériques dont il
puisque les réactions des numériques
une mairie qui serait que juste et plus
équitable et notamment sur les
territoires web le réalisent leurs
activités la deuxième vous avez évoqué
l'efficience de la dépense publique
quel est votre point de vue dans ce
domaine au niveau de la future politique
de décentralisation et notamment nous
avons députés et sénateurs mis en
évidence la fragilité de l'hôpital
celle de de santé néanmoins nous sommes
sans doute nous sommes assurément le
pays qui mobilise ont le plus de moyens
de 100 milliards et un lien au niveau de
l'hôpital public
comment voyez-vous peut-être le
renforcement d'un entre acheter les
domaines gouvernance territoriale au
niveau des régions et des départements
voilà l merci beaucoup de prendre la
parole est à joël labbé je suis anne
marie bertrand je vous demande vraiment
de d'éviter trop les déclarations pour
vous concentrer sur les questions merci
beaucoup
la bt sénateur du morbihan ou questions
rapides et cours d'amis chalets dont
leclerc puis une rapide et courtes à
monsieur xavier ragot monsieur leclerc
dont notre agriculture va mal vous le
savez un agriculteur sur 4 j à la limite
du seuil de pauvreté ou en dessous le
risque de suicide on travaille avec
notre collègue henri cabanel sur la sur
la détresse d agriculture donc il y a un
vrai malaise
la gms comme l'industrie agroalimentaire
devrait pouvoir avoir un rôle à jouer
là-dedans
visiblement ne joue pas je veux savoir
quelle très bonne solution monsieur
souhaiterait apporter à cela quant à
l'ia cela monsieur leclerc a dit qu'un
nombre important de nos concitoyens vont
vers les produits low cost faute de
pouvoir faire mieux et il y a une idée
qui germe et qu'il est en train
d'avancer qui sortira je le pense est ce
que la question de la sécurité sociale
alimentaire de l'ordre de 150 euros par
mois et par personne
vers des produits alimentaires
conventionnée de telle sorte qu'on
avance pour tout le monde vers une une
alimentation de qualité de proximité de
saisonnalité respectueuse de
l'environnement et respectueuse des
revenus des agriculteurs
je souhaiterais savoir avant une
réaction sur ago là-dessus formation
merci joël had marie bertrand
et ensuite sylvia noël merci madame la
présidente merci pour cette table ronde
ma question s'adresse à madame overgame
ordinaire dans le blog de votre
fondation vous mettez en évidence la
forte réactivité des collectivités
notamment les communes et régions les
départements et notamment dans cette
crise heureusement qu'ils étaient là
vous engager plus de la décentralisation
mais selon vous cette crise serait
l'occasion de mettre en place le système
de péréquation italien
nous avions étudié dans un rapport
d'information au sénat cependant la
principale difficulté de sa mise en
oeuvre et la nécessité de définir un
niveau minimum de service public local
la question est donc la science ne
serait ce pas nui a dit ok la
décentralisation vous remercie merci
beaucoup je donne la parole à sylviane
l'ol ensuite viviane artigalas merci
madame la présidente et merci à
l'ensemble de nos intervenants pour la
qualité de coco j'aurais de questions et
une très courte remarques ma première
question à agnès verdier j'ai bien
compris de vos miliciens en faveur d'une
dette sur le plus long terme certes les
taux d'intérêt actuels s'y prête
particulièrement mais ne pensez vous pas
qu'il s'agisse là d'un pari assez
dangereux dans la pièce d'à côté des
taux d'intérêt directeur qui mettrait
particulièrement à mal la dette de notre
pays
deuxième question qui s'adresse la à
michel edouard leclerc
suite à la crise du crédit de nombreux
producteurs français et notamment en
matière de production laitière ce outre
en raison d'une d'une transformation un
petit peu enfin en tout cas d'un
changement de consommation de nos goûts
nos concitoyens pardon ma question est
la suivante pour inciter la consommation
des produits made in france
envisageriez vous un espèce de fonds de
solidarité qui sont régulés par la
grande distribution notamment pour
orienter la promotion commerciale à
destination de vos clients
et qui cible en priorité les produits
made in france
et puis une très courte remarche n'ai
pas entendu parler il me semble les
intervenants de la problématique des 35
heures dans notre pays qui à mon avis
aubert énormément la compétitivité de
nos entreprises et de nos
administrations depuis plus de 20 ans
voilà jour merci merci sylviane viviane
artigalas et évelyne renou garabédian
ensuite dit merci madame la présidente
merci mes chers collègues et merci aussi
aux intervenants la question de le
désigner égalité d'accès
particulièrement pour les ménages les
plus modestes que pour les jeunes et
pour d'autres catégories lac cet accès
aux produits de première nécessité tels
que les produits alimentaires ont été
évoqués et particulièrement l'accès à
des produits de qualité donc je ne
reviendrai pas là-dessus certaines
solutions ont été proposées mais je
trouve quand même que ce débat n'est pas
assez prégnant dans que cette question
dépasse est prégnante dans notre débat
de sept-îles actuelle parce qu'à mon
avis on a eu la crise et des idées jaune
et cette question là va entraîner des
tensions sociales extrêmement importante
elle a pris le confinement avec le
déconfinement qui vont durer à mon avis
longtemps et je crois qu'on devrait être
centrale dans notre débat met donc une
question très précise à monsieur ragots
on vous avait parlé de la baisse de la
tva
quels secteurs semblent prioritaires
pour cette baisse est surtout comment
tout on est assuré que cette baisse de
la tva va être profitable justement aux
ménages les plus modestes et ceux qui
sont en plus le plus en difficulté pour
pour consommer merci merci et viviane
evelyne renault garabédian et ensuite
daniel grémillet merci madame la
présidente
ma première question s'adresse à prêtres
et martin au sein d'une cellule de
veille sur les conséquences du cowitz au
tourisme
les acteurs du tourisme que nous avons
auditionné ont plaidé et obtenu de la
part du gouvernement l'élargissement du
dispositif des chèques vacances
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur les
mesures qu un tel mécanisme apporterait
à la relance de la con
passion ma deuxième question s'adresse à
michel edouard leclerc
monsieur le président les français n'ont
jamais autant épargné que pendant la
période du confinement
en deux mois les flux nets mais dépourvu
s'élève à 20 milliards d'euros et 10 7
milliards sur les dépôts rémunérés des
crédits à la consommation est également
et massivement été renégociés considérez
vous qu'il s'agisse d'une épargne de
circonstances ou de précaution et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis en tant que
dirigeant entreprises pour savoir s'il
considérait et quels sont les outils
qu'il faudrait mettre en place pour que
ce que les français ont accumulé puisse
être dépensé pour favoriser la relance
merci de vos réponses merci beaucoup et
viennent daniel grémillet site franck
montaugé daniel alors c'est daniel n'est
pas là nous allons prendre directement
franck montaugé et ensuite bernard lui
merci madame la présidente merci à
quatre personnes qui se sont exprimées
c'était vraiment très intéressant je
pouvais revenir sur ce qu'a dit monsieur
rabbo au delà de la question clé
finalement de la manière dont sera où
pourraient être mobilisés l'épargné les
80 milliards d'euros accumulée en 24
mois
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait par
des mécanismes adaptés orienter cette
épargne vers de l'investissement durable
fléché peut-être partir de deux liserés
adaptées peut être plus performant que
ce qu'on a pu connaître à une époque
voilà pour les fléchés vers les
entreprises qui sont engagés réellement
concrètement et qu'ils peuvent en faire
la démonstration dans la transition de
deux modèles de modèle voilà et première
question mais deuxième deuxième question
qui est qui est lié ne faut-il pas selon
vous reconsidérer nos critères
d'évaluation de la richesse de la
richesse économique mais aussi sociale
environnementale
on ne peut pas résumer voilà la
prospérité d'une économie dorénavant on
le sait depuis pas mal de temps à son
seul produit intérieur brut
donc ne faut-il pas aller vers des
nouveaux indicateurs de richesse qui
serait opérationnel se poser aussi la
question des évolutions de la structure
même du budget de l'état de la mise en
place de normes frs révisé concernant
donc les entreprises à l'échelle la plus
large possible et donc que en
conséquence de quoi les entreprises
prennent des décisions sur des critères
qui intègre voilà les enjeux de la
transition de manière générale comme
j'aurais voulu savoir sur ces points si
vous pensez que ce sont des pistes à
privilégier pour déboucher sur une autre
façon de voir la question de la
postérité connu merci merci franck et
pour terminer bernard bûcher merci
beaucoup merci présidente remercie aux
intervenants à ma question s'adresse à
monsieur leclerc
elle porte sur la part des achats auprès
des producteurs locaux pour votre groupe
et est ce que vous envisagez de
l'augmenter merci merci de cette
rapidité cette question je vais pour des
questions pratiques donner la parole
d'abord à patrick martin 3 qui l'a dit
souci d'horaires et ensuite peut-être
mais pardon je voudrais revenir d'un mot
sur ce que el sawy ragot a dit du
dialogue social en france
juste une petite nuance mais qui
n'altère pas la pertinence de ce qu'il a
pu dire sur le dialogue social en
allemagne
en réalité la cogestion c'est un peu un
mythe parce que lorsqu'il véritablement
la locomotive de l'économie allemande
est fameuse lincoln a embarqué il ya
très peu de cogestion ce n'est pas le
jugement valeur ma part mais pour
revenir à la france
ok des problèmes que l'on a on est prêts
on est très demandeur de l'autonomie des
partenaires sociaux
le problème dans la deux problèmes le
premier problème c'est que nos syndicats
ça n'est pas non plus un jugement de
valeur sont composés plus d'adhérents
issus du secteur public que du secteur
privé
les logiques des uns et des autres ne
sont pas forcément les mêmes et
d'ailleurs les syndicalistes issus du
secteur public souhaite le renforcement
du secteur public bien souvent passent
par là les prélèvements obligatoires la
deuxième chose c'est que l'état et ça
pour le coup ça renvoie ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure de notre crainte d'une
étatisation plus marqué encore de
l'économie du pays l'état
déresponsabilise nous déresponsabilise
puisque en faisant savoir c'était le cas
typiquement sur l'assurance chômage que
en dernier recours c'est lui qui
décidera
il conduit les uns et les autres ça peut
être le patronat d'ailleurs au cas par
cas à se défausser sur l'état de
discussion ou de décisions difficiles
et puis par ailleurs éludé
déresponsabilise en ce sens que il
garanti les dettes sociales a
typiquement celle de l'unedic qui soit
dit en passant pour l'essentiel est issu
de décisions qui ont été imposées par
l'état si on remet si vous permettez
l'église au milieu du village
les partenaires sociaux à subir beaucoup
à la responsabilité des plus de
pragmatisme est en tout cas cette crise
a démontré une chose très intéressante
c'est que le dialogue social s'est
beaucoup développée en entreprise
beaucoup alors mais toujours en exergue
que les quelques cas notamment ceux qui
a évoqué agnès verdier-molinié tout à
l'heure et qui sont parfaitement vrai
d'attitude générait jusqu'au boutiste de
telle ou telle fédération seins nus en
moyenne des cas le dialogue était d'une
grande qualité et ça beaucoup plus que
les protocoles élaborés par le ministère
du travail contribuer à ce que
l'activité puisse reprendre dans les
entreprises même s'il parle de la
responsabilité pénale des chefs
d'entreprise n'a pas été complètement
évacué pardon de répondre simplement sur
ce point sur radio j 2 comme mon propos
la loi la loi
le projet de loi qui a été votée par
vous même des dames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi pour développer un nouveau type
d'activité partielle en substitution
complément du régime général
c'est l'illustration parfaite de ce que
j'ai dit je trouve que c'est une
initiative de la bête
l'orgie et du ménage mais il ya eu
aucune concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
aucune consultation d'ailleurs dès
vendredi matin lors d'une réunion nous
avons vu avec madame pélico toutes les
centrales syndicales se sont émus que ce
texte de loi était votée présenté et
voté sans qu'aucun à aucune organisation
ni pas trop mal vie syndicale ne soit
consulté préalablement gens reviennent
donc à cette question sur un chèque
vacances et les tickets restaurant oui
on est on est très favorable au
développement de ses outils de
consommation en définitive à la réserve
près que dans l'état où sont des
entreprises actuellement les résultats
des entreprises
notre idée c'est que ces chèques soit
abondé par par les pouvoirs publics de
sorte que on stimule la consommation
mais en ciblant en particulier sur cette
filière tourisme qu'on a lui même
beaucoup soutenu et qu'il faut
appréhender d'ailleurs d'une manière
assez globale on se réjouit passant peu
transport de voyageurs bénéficient plus
durablement dorénavant de de l'activité
partielle mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
secteurs sont et les ferries de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration de la
culture de l'événementiel des parcs
d'attractions etc qui ont été très
sévèrement attaqué ce qu'il faut c'est
que c'est que les pouvoirs publics
exceptionnellement soutiennent la
demande en direction sur la consommation
d'une manière générale en direction de
ces secteurs puisque par définition ça
répond à une autre question
ça ne contribuera pas à notre déficit
commercial
voilà je suis absolument désolé de
devoir vous quittez la présidente
dams et messieurs les sénateurs merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président on
aura l'occasion de poursuivre cette
conversation voilà d'autres d'autres
formes
merci beaucoup madame agnès
verdier-molinié si vous voulez répondre
aux différentes questions qui vous ont
été posées oui alors une des premières
questions c'était le paradoxe de
demander à l'état d'intervenir le même
temps de vouloir baisser les dépenses ça
me paraît pas être un paradoxe dans le
pays le plus dépensier et le plus taxé
si l'état n'intervenait pas alors même
que nos entreprises n'ont pas pu
faire les réserves parce qu'il ya ce
niveau de taxe beaucoup plus important
il ya moins de trésorerie il ya plus de
dettes dans nos entreprises donc on a
malgré tout encore plus besoin
d'intervention alors après et c'est pour
ça que nous proposons à la fondation
ifrap d'avoir un état mieux gérer pour
qu'ils aient moins besoin de fonctionner
d'entreprise et qu'on est en moins
besoin de lui
tout se tient et est donc voilà je ne
trouve pas qu'il ya un paradoxe en la
matière ensuite il ya beaucoup de sujets
sur la décentralisation
oui nous appelons de nouveau la
décentralisation parce que les pays qui
ont réussi à moins confiné sont aussi
des pays beaucoup plus décentralisée qui
ont pris des décisions plus local et qui
les ont prises aussi simplement avec la
bonne remontée du terrain à moi j'ai été
frappé de ce qui s'est passé entre les
préfets et les maires et maires qui
voulait imposer le masque les préfets
qui ne voulaient pas parce que l'état
disait que c'était pas la peine imposée
le masque dans l'espace public etc
il faut beaucoup plus de souplesse et on
a vu les ars qui intervenait aussi alors
que les régions n'ont pas vraiment voix
au chapitre dans ce que font les ars
donc là il ya tout un sujet aussi sur la
répartition des compétences les régions
doivent piloter la santé à terme doivent
piloter l'éducation on aurait été
beaucoup plus réactifs dans la crise est
beaucoup plus décentralisée sur nos
décisions
si on avait un système comme celui là
malheureusement l'état quand il
décentralisant france et vous le savez
bien
en tant qu'élu il décentralise mais une
petite partie de sa mission c'est à dire
que par exemple effet gérer le nettoyage
la cantine des lycées l'entretien des
bâtiments mais pas l' embauche des
professeurs et bien ça ça doit plus
continuer comme ça parce que l'on montre
que l'agilité c'est aussi ce qui se gère
au niveau local au plus proche du
terrain avec des responsables élus qui
sont aussi devant les citoyens et ça
fonctionne beaucoup mieux comme ça c'est
pour ça que je pense que cette crise va
vraiment nous faire prendre conscience
de ce nouvel acte de décentralisation
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on mène et
même si la sénatrice m'a dit finalement
le modèle italien est ce que c'est bien
et c'est ce qui est intéressant dans le
modèle italien sait que ou valorise les
bons gestionnaires et moi ce qui
m'apparaît depuis des années a dans nos
travaux de la fondation ifrap c'est que
quand les collectivités locales gèrent
bien on a tendance à leur couper des
crédits au lieu de valoriser leurs
bonnes actions en termes de gestion
publique
nous avons tout fait nous à la fondation
ifrap pour essayer de comparer les
gestion publique entre collectivités
comparable on va continuer à le faire et
montrer qu'il est possible à la fois de
baisser la fiscalité de baisser la dette
tout en investissant et il ya énormément
de collectivités locales notamment des
des communes qui l'ont montré ces
dernières années est juste une petite
incursion sur un dernier sujet sur
lequel on n'a pas vraiment posé de
questions mais ces milliards d'epargne
là je pense que il faut aussi se c'est
l'investissement c'est le sujet de
l'investissement kg doit prédominer
on peut faire des mesures incitatives
sur l'impôt sur le revenu pour investir
dans des entreprises notamment les tpe
pme
on aura beaucoup besoin dans les mois et
les années qui viennent et vous savez
bien qu'il ya une mesure hier pme qui
existent déjà qui devait être boostée
par le gouvernement l'amendement
finalement n'a jamais été véritablement
appliquée pourquoi parce que ça a été
bloquée il n'y a pas eu de demande
véritable à la commission européenne
tout ça a été totalement bloquée pour
augmenter vraiment cette mesure hier pme
qui permet de déduire de son impôt sur
le revenu
une somme importante investit en capital
d'une tpe d'une pme ça c'est très
important de revenir là dessus on peut
aussi comme nous l'avons proposée dans
le plan la fondation ifrap faire un
moratoire sur les bmtn des dmtg pendant
quelques mois voire un an pour permettre
de plus d'investissements dans
l'immobilier et plus de circulation
aussi entre les générations avec les dmt
hausse et les dmtg des finalement d'un
non taxation des donations entre
générations qui permettrait de faire
circuler aussi l' épargne entre
générations ça c'est hyper important
parce que vous savez bien que ceux qui
ont le moins perdu de revenus c'est
aussi les générations les plus avancés
qui se retrouvaient pas au chômage
et c'est donc qu'ils étaient à la
retraite et qui finalement ou moins
perdu en revenus donc il faut faire
circuler l'epargne aussi entre
générations et se dire que on ne
taxerait pas les donations
quelles que soient les montants sur
plusieurs mois voire un an voire un an
et demi ça permettrait aussi beaucoup de
faire investir cette épargne notamment
par les jeunes générations
voilà très bien merci merci beaucoup et
je vais laisser la parole à michel
edouard leclerc et nous finirons par
xavier ragot michel edouard leclerc t de
cette audience de ce débat et c'est très
intéressant ça nous enrichi
personnellement je m'aperçois que l'on
peut grandir comme ça dans une
félicitation je vous mets des like c'est
je vais répondre
il ya trois groupes de questions qui
étaient peut-être un peu plus adressés à
ma personne
alors il y avait des rapports avec
l'agriculture d'abord je voudrais dire
qu'on a bien travaillé avec toute la
chaîne alimentaire pendant là je vous le
redis pendant le qu'ovide faut savoir
que tous les jours à 14h on était en
ligne avec christiane lambert avec
gérard theaux de l'ania avec des patrons
de l'agroalimentaire de danone ou de
lactalis avec eux donc ça ça en fait les
problèmes étaient évoqués chacun a
essayé d'apporter sa contribution est
par ailleurs on se rappelait et et au
fond on a quand même pas mal travaillé
tous les distributeurs j'ai pas tiré là
le truc à moi mais je pense que si
toutes les opérations de promotion des
produits agricoles français que vous
avez vu elle était compliqué à monter
parce que il n'y avait pas arriver en
plus stéphane météo il y avait des
problèmes de d'indisponibilité de
rupture mais je pense que tout le monde
a joué le jeu et dans les suites dans la
filière il ya un dialogue qui c'est
c'est bien construit alors moi ce que je
voudrais c'est que justement on utilise
la qualité de ce dialogue
pour le coup d'après aujourd'hui bon là
les produits étaient très cher il y
avait aussi des raisons météo des
raisons de
dawn l'approvisionnement du marché qui
rendait le dispositif très très atypique
on s'est fait beaucoup reculé et pas que
dans les réseaux sociaux sur le prix des
fruits et légumes mais en fait je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de problème à
revaloriser la production agricole
si on trouve les signes de qualité si on
les rend visible et si on argumente les
différences de prix et pour vous montrer
qu'il ya pas entité tisme entre la
grande distribution quelles que soient
les enseignes et l'agriculture on l'a
vachement bien fait sur les produits
viticoles les foires aux vins sont un
succès mondial
les caves à vin dans la grande
distribution et pourtant vous trouvez
des vins d'entrée de gamme à 4,5 euros
et des très grands crus à plus de 100
euros et tout cela qu à bille et c'est
le consommateur qui choisit et
finalement la viticulture française n'a
plus peur de l'importation
on en est même à rajouter pour avoir
l'air correct du vin italien du vin
américain ou du vin sud-africain pour
faire joli dans le rayon mais c'est la
production française qui remplit toutes
les casses parce qu'elle a su travailler
sa valeur ajoutée elle a su vendre ces
signes de qualité donc c'est ce modèle
là moi qui me tire et oui j'en suis
passionnée dans le retour au local dans
le retour à la production française et à
la localisation
pour moi le chantier c'est moins une
financement on va reparler mais c'est
moins le financement que
l'investissement par l'agriculture elle
même dans son propre programme de
transformation et de valorisation des
produits
ils ont laissé sa l'industrie
agroalimentaire la plupart des
groupements soit qu'ils reprennent ça
c'est là où la valeur et puis c'est dans
la la qualité des signes de qualité
traçabilité la valorisation le port
breton si ça le dico port breton un
alsacien va pas acheter du porc breton
donc il faut dire en plus sa qualité
donc facile à dire mais à développer
mais en tout cas il ya une vraie volonté
chez nous de le faire
ces soi-disant assuré après sur les
problèmes de de bas salaires
et puis de revenu universel où il le
revenu universel
c'est une question
intéressante et je pense qui va nous
arriver avec l'extension de la
robotisation parce que la relocalisation
ça va pas se faire à coût de production
supplémentaires dont vous allez voir ce
faire attention
la réindustrialisation c'est une chose
la relocalisation avec des coûts et pas
simplement des impôts de production que
les élever ça va être un coup
d'accélérateur pour la digitalisation et
la robotisation très vite les thèses
d'andry gorce les thèses sur la fin du
travail ils vont ressurgir et donc le
revenu non liés au travail
c'est vraiment un concept qui va
s'imposer je suis absolument convaincu
de ça maintenant dans la période et
avant que ça n'arrive pas ce que c'est
pas en même temps là dans la période
ça arrive moi je pense que la priorité
c'est la revalorisation des bas salaires
le président de la république avait
l'air de redécouvrir en tout cas l'a
repris à son compte et je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée dans une grande
partie de l'industrie française même
exportatrices n'est pas dépendante de
ses coûts de salaire je peux parler que
du luxe mais il ya il ya des secteurs de
l'économie qui peuvent valoriser ses
salaires tout le secteur des services
qui est très peu impactée finalement par
la concurrence internationale y compris
le mien pourrait par des accords de
branche travailler sur une perspective
positive d'augmentation des bas salaires
donner à chaque salarié une perspective
concrète
je trouve que toutes ces idées sur les
chèques les avantages des transferts
tout ce qu'on donne autour du salaire ne
donnera jamais aux salariés la sécurité
lié à son travail et l' envie de
travailler donc c'est autour de ce sujet
là si je vous en cours que je milite
voyez je suis pas un ultralibéral vous
me direz pourquoi vous commencez par
chez vous parce que justement c'est très
compliqué de le commencer tout seul et
tout seul on le fait par l'intéressement
et la participation mais si on veut
aller sur l'augmentation des salaires
réels
il faut passer par des accords de
branche je pense que ça c'est une une
réalité et après il y avait la question
du fonds de solidarité
fonds de solidarité pour qui pour quoi
j'avais cette idée j'avais eu cette idée
là il ya pas très longtemps justement
pour les problèmes agricoles
mais les besoins sont tellement énorme
par rapport à ce qu'on appelle le mass
market que ça me paraît très
difficilement conciliable avec des bases
de financement limitées qu'avec des
cotisants limité donc si toute
l'industrie agroalimentaire re cotiser à
des fonds propres et investir en amont
ça pourrait faire sens
mais je vous rappelle quand même que le
montant des masses d'argent europe +
france qui sont déjà dirigées vers
l'agriculture son dos lors de ces puces
et 70 milliards sur dix ans peut-être
même 100 milliards donc le fonds de
solidarité c'est peut-être un sujet dans
le sujet mais d'abord c'est le prenne de
la réaffectation de ces sommes vers une
agriculture qui transforme plus et qui
valorise plus en tout cas qui va dans le
sens d'une économie plus verte voilà et
dernier mot monsieur martin est
peut-être parti mais on parle beaucoup
de l'élargissement de la base du
financement de tout ça il ya un sujet
qu'on aborde plus je sais pas si je suis
hors course mais il me semble que
l'impôt de consommation pour un juste
qu'il soit n'est pas plus injuste que
l'impôt que lui rpp ou mal ficelé où la
csg csg photo kc un problème qui peut se
résoudre mais quand même faire payer les
importations faire payer y compris les
masques chinois et y compris
l'électronique et la data quand elle est
importée la tva sociale l'idée de la tva
sociale
l'idée de la fiscalisation des charges
sociales c'est comme une piste qu'il
faut pas abandonner maintenant alors que
l'inflation est est quasi nulle
hormis des secteurs particuliers c'est
quand même le moment où on pourrait
reposer le problème de la tva sociale
c'est à dire l'élargissement la plus
large possible de l'assiette fiscale de
manière à ce qu'on puisse transférer le
financement les
écoute production les charges de
production vers un partage notamment du
reste par le reste du monde
voilà voilà pour cette table ronde
organisée par le sénat sur la relance de
l'économie
je vous propose maintenant de suivre les
débats qui ont eu lieu dans l'hémicycle
de la haute assemblée puisque le sénat a
adopté hier une proposition de loi pour
faciliter le vote lors du second tour
des élections municipales le 28 juin
prochain et les sénateurs ont autorisé
le vote par correspondance
un vote pourtant interdite depuis 1975
juhasz écouter les débats
nous sommes appelés aujourd'hui à
discuter un texte qui je l'espère
permettra de contribuer par des
aménagements judicieux du droit
électoral au bon déroulement du second
tour des élections municipales il ne
vous aura pas échappé que la portée de
la proposition de loi a grandement
évolué par rapport à son objectif
initial tel qu'il figurait dans la
première version que j'avais déposé en
mars 2017
cet objectif c'était ni plus ni moins
que de faciliter et de sécuriser le
recours aux procurations électorale la
procuration si elle dérange
effectivement aux principes
constitutionnels du secret du vote n'en
demeure pas moins lorsqu'elle est
correctement employés un outil
indispensable au bon fonctionnement
d'une démocratie moderne
n'oublions pas que déjà dans l'athènes
de périclès tous les citoyens ne
pouvaient pas dans la pratique se rendre
quotidiennement sur le qnx pour voter et
que la démocratie en souffrait a
fortiori et à une époque où notre
société devient toujours plus complexes
où elle est confrontée à une crise
sanitaire inédite lusage de la
procuration prend tout son sens il doit
être de rendu aussi effectif que
possible faciliter l'acte de vote est un
impératif démocratique et c'est notre
rôle à nous parlementaires que d'en
faciliter l'établissement
or certains obstacles existent
actuellement à cet exercice effectif
en effet depuis le décret de
simplification en matière électorale du
11 octobre 2006 l'information du
mandataire de l'existence d'une
procuration n'est plus automatique
danser dans les termes employés par la
circulaire ministérielle d'alors il
revient désormais aux mandants d'assurer
l'information de son mandataire
si cette solution peut pour d'aucuns
apparaître intuitive elle avait
probablement aussi l'immense qualité de
faciliter la vie de la demie
ration en évitant l'envoi d'un courrier
recommandé aux mandataires
malheureusement cela revient surtout à
l'essai nombre d'électeurs dans le flou
il arrive donc régulièrement que le
mandant oublie de notifier le mandataire
de l'établissement de la procuration
dans cette situation malgré le fait
qu'il a bien établi la procuration dans
les règles le mandant air son vote
pire dans l'éventualité où plusieurs
personnes établirait des procurations au
bénéfice d'un mandataire sans que ce
dernier ne soit informée de l'ensemble
de celles ci ce qui là aussi est chose
courante
seule la première devant demeura valable
dans ce scénario il serait possible que
le mandataire ignorent l'existence de la
seule des procurations être
effectivement valable le choix de
renoncer à l'information automatique du
mandataire anne ont créé un angle mort
administratif aussi superflu
qu'ennuyeuse y remédier et est l'objet
principal de ma proposition de loi celle
ci avait été redéposé en octobre dernier
à cette époque locaux vides 19 n'avait
pas encore fait son apparition avoine
depuis les événements que nous
connaissons tristement bien se sont
produits le déroulement des élections
municipales de mars 2020 est est
grandement perturbé et leur second tour
a été reporté à la fin du mois de juin
durant la crise le sénat a agi avec
responsabilité exigeant sur le contrôle
de l'action du gouvernement est toujours
précautionneux sur la santé publique
il a aussi été force de proposition
permettez moi de saluer ici les travaux
de tous les collègues sénateurs qui ont
contribué à ce que la démocratie ne soit
pas confinés durant les derniers mois
c'est dans le cadre de ces travaux que
le président bah les président bart ayo
et marseille ont déposé le 22 mai
dernier une proposition de loi visant à
mieux protéger les électeurs et les
candidats pour le second tour des
élections municipales de juin 2020
l'objectif de ce texte était de
contribuer à la réalisation d'un
équilibre entre d'une part l'impératif
de protection de la santé de nos
concitoyens et d'autre part la nécessité
d'assurer le bon fonctionnement des
institutions démocratiques municipal car
repousser les élections n'est pas une
décision dont la prise pourrait se faire
à la légère
sur le plan des principes cela signifie
relativiser la fixité et la périodicité
des mandats
sur le plan pratique cela contribuerait
à ralentir l'investissement public local
au moment même où l'économie est en
grande souffrance pour atteindre cet
équilibre la proposition de loi des
trois présidents prévoyait plusieurs
démarches convergentes d'abord d'assurer
une organisation du scrutin plus adaptée
aux circonstances en sécurisant les
procurations déjà établis en élargissant
le recours aux procurations et en
facilitant l'accès aux votes des
personnes vulnérables
ensuite d'offrir une meilleure
protection de tous les participants
en dotant les bureaux de vote des
équipements nécessaires et en prévoyant
la prise en charge de ses frais par
l'état enfin de faire en sorte que les
pouvoirs publics seront informés de la
situation sanitaire par le conseil
scientifique suffisamment en amont pour
le cas échéant
car report en bon ordre du scrutin
demeure possible compte tenu de la
hausse de plus de 18 points de
l'abstention lors du premier tour et de
la possibilité d'une seconde vague de
l'épidémie
ces mesures dérogatoires qui ne
concernait que cette élection semble
essentiel afin d'établir de rétablir
pardon la confiance des électeurs
cependant un tel texte n'aurait pas pu
être inscrit à l'ordre du jour à temps
pour les élections
dès lors la commission des lois a choisi
d'employer ma proposition de loi comme
véhicule législatif pour ces mesures
gens là prouve évidemment pleinement la
direction et du travail de la commission
et de son rapporteur françois noël
buffet dont je salue l'excellent travail
je défendrai aussi tout à l'heure
plusieurs amendements visent et visant à
préciser certaines dispositions du texte
dans l'esprit qui avait et il était
celui de du projet initial l'un d'entre
eux a vocation à inscrire dans le droit
dur l'article 1er tel qu'il sera
éventuellement amenés à demander pardon
par des propositions cet article
organise l'information du mandataire de
l'existence de la procuration
il me semble en effet souhaitable qu'à
l'avenir pour toutes les élections
les mandataires sont informés de
l'existence de la procuration par voie
électronique ou par voie postale
l'ajout de son mail dans le formulaire
devrait pouvoir régler le problème très
facilement je propose également que les
autorités compétentes informe
systématiquement en voie électronique
la préfecture du département du
mandataire
et la préfecture est la préfecture en
informe à son tour également par voie
électronique la commune du mandataire
compte tenu des délais très courts qui
seront imposées il serait regrettable
que les délais postaux joue contre nous
et que les procurations n'est pas été
n'est pas été acheminée en mairie et
soit donc perdu cette disposition
permettrait également un mandant de
voter par procuration jusqu'au jour du
scrutin en cas d'empêchement carte vous
le savez très bien dans les faits cette
faculté était très souvent inopérante du
fait du délai d'acheminement
enfin si nous voulons faciliter
effectivement le vote par procuration
pour les élections de juin
il faut aussi en simplifier les
conditions il est donc impératif de
permettre aux électeurs de saisir les
autorités compétentes par tous moyens en
vue du second tour des élections
municipales y compris par téléphone quel
intérêt pour l'autorité administrative
d'exiger parfois une lettre du mandant
requérant le déplacement de l'autorité à
son domicile
je dis parfois car d'un département à
l'autre et quelquefois dans le même
département les exigences des autorités
varient l'autorité administrative qui se
déplace et parfaitement en capacité pour
juger de la volonté du mandant et de sa
capacité à donner mandat à un tiers pour
preuve lorsque l'autorité considère le
mandant inapte elle n'établit pas la
procuration
les documents justificatifs nécessaires
au déplacement des autorités compétentes
doivent également être allégée je
propose que ces dernières se déplace
sans exiger de justificatifs préalable
quelqu un certificat médical dans nos
campagnes où il est difficile de trouver
un médecin imaginez la difficulté que
cette démarche représente et son coût
là aussi l'autorité compétente est
parfaitement en capacité de constater
qu'une personne ne peut pas se déplacer
pour conclure j'espère qu'en adoptant
cette proposition de loi le sénat
enverra un signal fort évidemment aux
électeurs mais également aux
organisateurs de l'élection
ces petites mains qui dans chaque
commune font vivre notre démocratie se
signale ce message c'est qu'il sera
possible d'organiser des élections aux
meilleurs standards démocratiques tout
en assurant la protection sanitaire
irréprochable des participants je reste
ici aussi au gouvernement au cours des
derniers mois
il nous a démontré sa capacité à faire
preuve d'une grande célérité pour
l'adoption de ces projets de loi
pourtant bien plus long et plus complexe
que ce que cette modeste ppr espérons
que cet activisme ne se limite pas aux
seules zones ibus pourtant diverses
ordonnances jadis jacques coeur avait
adopté pour devise
à coeur vaillant rien d'impossible je ne
veux je ne peux que vous inciter
monsieur le ministre à faire preuve de
vaillance sur ce texte sénatorial dont
l'adoption finale n'a rien d'impossible
merci beaucoup merci merci chers
collègues dans la discussion générale la
parole est à présent au président
philippe bas en remplacement de monsieur
françois noël buffet rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour dix minutes
cher collègue monsieur le président je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je vous demande
d'excusés notre rapporteur françois noël
buffet je vais faire de mon mieux pour
le supplée en son absence
monsieur le ministre nous aurons 28 juin
sauf événement contraire la convocation
de 16 millions et demi d'électeurs 16
millions et demi d'électeurs appelés aux
urnes pour désigner les conseils
municipaux de 4850 cette commune de
toutes dimensions
certaines parmi les plus grandes de
france ce scrutin a fait l'objet de
beaucoup d'incertitudes
il ya quelques semaines encore nous
étions en plein confinement personne
n'imaginait que l'on pourrait le tenir
le gouvernement a finalement décidé de
convoquer les électeurs par un décret
pris mercredi dernier et nous sommes
maintenant sur cette voie de l'élection
il n'empêche que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens sont pour partie anxieux à
l'idée de s'exposer à la promiscuité
dans les bureaux de vote malgré toutes
les mesures d'organisation qui pourront
être prises d'autres étant
particulièrement vulnérables ou ayant
été malades ou étant encore affaiblie
par la main
10 exit à se rendre aux urnes
souhaitons qu'ils aillent mieux d'ici le
28 mai il nous paraît tout à fait
essentiel que des mesures soient prises
pour rassurer et nous comptions le faire
en parfaite harmonie avec le
gouvernement et la majorité
parlementaire
car il s'agit de notre point de vue le
point de vue républicain d'un impératif
d'intérêt supérieur pour le bon
fonctionnement de la démocratie
nous espérions donc que notre
proposition visant à faciliter les
procurations pour ce seul scrutin du 28
juin qui a fait l'objet de beaucoup
d'expressions positive y compris dans
les rangs de la majorité parlementaire
pourrait aboutir en temps utile pour
cela encore eût-il fallu que le
gouvernement déclenche la procédure
accélérée
c'est une procédure qui lui est
normalement assez familière puisque
jusqu'à présent nous avons pratiquement
discuter de tous les textes du
gouvernement selon cette procédure
mais le gouvernement alors qu'il ne
s'est pas opposée aux dispositions que
nous proposons n'a pas mobilisé cet
instrument constitutionnel et ce faisant
il prend la responsabilité et il apprend
seul d'empêcher l'assouplissement des
procurations et toutes autres mesures
qui pourraient être prises il ya aussi
des amendements qui porte sur le vote
par correspondance
je crois que cette demande a été fait
par un parti important de la majorité
sans lequel d'ailleurs la majorité n'est
plus la majorité
il nous en sommes là et au moment où je
dois au nom de notre rapporteur vous
présenter le dispositif que nous
proposons j'ai déjà hélas la certitude
que cette volonté de bien faire
fonctionner la démocratie au cours
du scrutin du 28 juin n'est pas partagée
par le gouvernement puisque il n'a pas
mobilisé les moyens nécessaires pour que
le régime des procurations soit
assouplie monsieur le ministre vous
allez vous en expliquer peut-être
trouverez-vous mon propos excessifs
si c'est le cas je le retirerais bien
sûr peut-être avez-vous songé à d'autres
instruments que la procédure accélérée
qui nous permettraient d'aboutir
j'ai vu par exemple que sur un projet de
loi qui reporte les élections
municipales qui devraient avoir lieu le
28 juin des amendements ont été déposés
je voudrais vous dire au cas où vous ne
vous en seriez pas aperçu que ce projet
de loi n'est pas fait pour tenir le
scrutin du 28 juin mais pour leur portée
je vois mal comment des amendements
relatifs au régime des procurations
pourrait donc servir pour le 28 juin
dans cette taxe est par ailleurs je me
demande aussi si ces amendements ne sont
pas de pures cavaliers c'est à dire ne
rendrait pas inconstitutionnelles les
dispositions qui pourraient alors être
adoptée mais en tout état de cause cette
législation en cours de discussion ne
pourra pas aboutir dans un temps
permettant d'organiser l'assouplissement
du régime des procurations
donc c'est un mauvais cheval quand
fourche ce cavalier
le seul bon cheval c'est le nôtre nous
avons souhaité faire en sorte qu'on
puisse utiliser deux qu'on puisse avoir
deux procurations au lieu d'une ça vous
choque peut-être nous avons fait en
sorte aussi qu'on puisse confier à son
fils à son petit-fils sa petite fille
une procuration alors même qu'elles ne
votent pas dans la même commune que
celle où on est soi-même électeurs ou
électrices si ça vous choque faut le
dire mais si ça ne vous choque pas
pourquoi ne coopéreront pas avec nous
pour permettre l'entrée en vigueur de
cette disposition en temps utile pour
que l'on puisse s'organiser afin qu'il
n'y ait pas
un taux trop élevé d'abstention je ne
vous fais pas le procès de croire que
vous souhaitez de l'abstention parce que
ce procès serait hors de propos je dois
vous dire d'ailleurs que de mon point de
vue quel que soit le taux d'abstention
les élus sont toujours des élus
légitimes
les français qui se déplacent pour voter
ont le pouvoir de décision
c'est si vrai qu'alors même que
l'abstention au second tour des
élections législatives de 2010 set a été
nettement plus élevé que l'abstention au
premier tour des élections municipales
de 2020 personne n'a jamais mis en cause
la légitimité de la majorité
parlementaire
eh bien on ne doit pas non plus mettre
en cause la légitimité des mers
lorsqu'ils sont élus avec un faible taux
de participation et pour autant je crois
qu'on doit à la république on doit à la
démocratie de faire en sorte que les
électeurs puissent largement se
mobiliser pour faire un choix car on l'a
bien vu pendant cette crise où les
communes ont été extrêmement réactive
comme les départements et les régions
le rôle des communes est extrêmement
important tant pour gérer l'épidémie que
pour sortir de l'épidémie et permette la
reprise de l'investissement et on ne
voit pas comment on pourrait refuser des
dispositions qui vise tout simplement à
ce que les français lorsqu'ils j'hésite
pour des raisons valables des raisons de
santé des raisons d'inquiétude tout
simplement puisse prendre part au vote
et puis nous proposons aussi des
dispositions qui vont tout à fait dans
le sens de ce que le premier ministre
lui même a proposé c'est à dire faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des masques à l'entrée
des bureaux de vote que ces masques soit
pris en charge par l'état non pas par la
commune et que l'organisation des
bureaux de vote présente toutes les
garanties nécessaires pour prévenir les
risques de contamination de même que de
faire en sorte que le dépouillement se
déroule dans des conditions qui assurent
curité sanitaire de ces opérations voilà
monsieur le ministre
toutes les raisons qui font que nous
attendons beaucoup au sénat du
gouvernement non pas pour nous mêmes
nous sommes complètement hors de cause
nous ne pouvons pas devenir mère vous le
savez bien
nous voulons simplement défendre la
libre expression du suffrage universel
en donnant à nos compatriotes les moyens
de voter même lorsqu'ils ont peur de
sortir de chez eux
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent monsieur laurent nunez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur savez la parole le ministre
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
vous l'avez dit la période que nous
avons traversée nous a conduit à changer
nos habitudes et bousculer nos usages
gestes barrières et distanciation
physique autant d'expressions que nous
ne connaissions pas ou à peine
il y a 6 mois et qui font aujourd'hui
partie prenante de notre quotidien
vous le savez en annonçant le 22 mai la
décision d'organisation du second tour
des élections municipales dans les prés
de 5000 communes où le premier tueur
tour n'avait pas été conclusif le
premier ministre a agi en conscience et
en responsabilités en conscience parce
que cette décision a été prise sur le
fondement de l'avis du conseil
scientifique et après avoir consulté
élus et formations politiques en
responsabilité parce qu'elle est assorti
d'un certain nombre d'obligations pour
la campagne et le vote afin d'assurer le
respect des gestes barrières et parce
que cette décision irréversible si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé
en ce moment même d'ailleurs la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale examine un projet de loi pour
nous préparer à cette éventualité
mais dans ce contexte et comme nous y
invite et le rapport du comité des
scientifiques du du comité scientifique
pas rebondi
8 mai dernier nous devons avoir aussi à
l'esprit plusieurs choses d'abord s'être
campagne électorale devra être différent
puisqu'elle exige un respect scrupuleux
des règles sanitaires et notamment de
distanciation physique
ensuite nous devons faire tout ce qui
est possible pour favoriser la
mobilisation des électeurs diminué
l'abstention et s'assurer que tous ceux
qui le souhaitent puissent voter à ce
sujet dès le 27 mai dernier avec le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner nous avons consulté les élus
comme les responsables de partis
politiques pour connaître leur sentiment
c'est sur le fondement de l'avis des
scientifiques et de ses consultations
que nous allons prendre des mesures pour
aménager les règles de la campagne
électorale ainsi que celles afférentes
aux opérations de vote proprement dit
nous préparons actuellement des mesures
par décret ainsi que par voie de
circulaire et j'y reviendrai évidemment
dans la discussion puisqu'un certain
nombre de mesures dont nous allons
débattre aujourd'hui il faut avoir aussi
le courage de le dire relève du pouvoir
réglementaire voire de la simple
circulaire et il faut aussi que les
français entendent cette réalité là
monsieur le président pour la campagne
électorale ces mesures consisteront à
assurer une offre gratuite d'hébergement
des professions de foi qui ont été
validés par la commission de propagande
électorale
et cette mesure a déjà été discuté avec
les responsables de partis politiques et
les responsables d'associations d'élus
d'autre part il s'agira de rendre
possible l'application d'une deuxième
affiche électorale et assurer la prise
en charge d'ailleurs des frais
d'impression par l'état s'agissant de
l'élection à proprement parler nous
interviendrons bien monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le rapporteur pour
assouplir le régime des procurations
pour élargir les cas où un délégué d'eau
pj peut se déplacer supprimer la
nécessité d'un motif pour établir une
procuration et permettre aux délégués
d'opodo pj
de recueillir des preuves des
procurations dans des lieux distincts
ouvert au public nous voyons bien
évidemment d'adresser au maire au
président du bureau de vote des
recommandations d'organisations des
bureaux de vote et du dépouillement pour
qu'elle se passe dans les meilleures
conditions sanitaires possible
évidemment évidemment seront pris en
charge les dispositifs de protection
sanitaire des électeurs et des personnes
participant à la tenue des bureaux de
vote
ces dernières dispositions sont
importantes car elles permettent de
montrer que l'on peut voter en confiance
et que toutes les mesures sanitaires ont
été prises
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président qu'il s'agisse des mesures
concernant les procurations
l'organisation des opérations de vote
nous avions réussi à les mettre en place
dans des délais restreints
avant le premier tour nous avons
aujourd'hui un mois devant nous un mois
pour nous préparer au mieux et
conjointement état et communes ensemble
comme nous l'avons toujours fait
permettre à chacun de pouvoir exprimer
son vote c'est j'en suis sûr monsieur le
sénateur cédric père à monsieur le
président bas monsieur le rapporteur
buffet mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs l'objet de cette proposition
de loi et nous n'en doutons le
gouvernement n'en doute absolument pas
le gouvernement n'est d'ailleurs pas
défavorable à la mesure centrale qu'elle
porte visant à porter à deux le nombre
de procurations kmm mandataire peut
détenir si le parlement souhaite
procéder à cette évolution pour le
second tour des élections municipales du
28 juin prochain à raison de la
permanence de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et du contexte épidémique que nous
continuons à connaître le gouvernement
soutiendra évidemment ces initiatives
mais il faut alors qu'elle les ait un
effet pleinement utile et notamment
qu'elle entre en vigueur à temps pour la
tenue du second tour qui se tient le 28
juin prochain et je crois que nous
partageons si j'en ai bien écouter le
président bah nous partageons toutes et
tous cette préoccupation à cet égard et
pardon il me semble que le projet de loi
par ailleurs en discussions constitue et
nous aurons un débat là-dessus
monsieur le président je notais
constitue un vecteur plus sûres
plus efficace compte tenu de l'urgence
au demeurant la présente proposition de
loi dont le gouvernement partage
l'ambition qu'elle traduit de faciliter
l'exercice du vote pose certaines
difficultés il faut savoir les souligné
ainsi informé le mandataire une
procuration a été accompli à son nom
ferait porter une lourde charge une
importante charge sur les fonctionnaires
de police et sur les mers cela
reviendrait sur l'avancé qui avait été
permise par un décret de février 2004
nicolas sarkozy était alors ministre de
l'intérieur qui prévoyait justement
cette fin de l'obligation d'information
du mandataire il s'agissait d'affirmer
que c'était à la personne qui faisait
une procuration d'avertir son mandataire
et non aux pouvoirs publics
cette position du ministre de
l'intérieur de 2004 nous paraît toujours
pertinente elle traduit par ailleurs le
fait que cette règle ne relève pas
surtout surtout du niveau législatif
puisqu'il avait été alors procéder par
décret d'autres difficultés prévisibles
résultera du texte présenté aujourd'hui
ainsi la capacité de disposer d'une
procuration hors de sa commune
d'inscription sur les listes électorales
pour un parent un enfant un frère ou une
soeur ne pourrait pas être vérifiées et
il faut savoir le dire monsieur le
président je vous ai entendu tout à leur
parler de cette mesure
évidemment qu elle satisfera la plupart
de nos concitoyens
c'est une mesure de bon sens mais encore
faut-il pouvoir la mettre en oeuvre dans
les délais requis
et je vous rappelle que ce sont
aujourd'hui les mères qui viennent ce
sont encore les maires qui vérifie qu'un
mandataire n'est pas porteur de plus
d'une procuration
or qu'en est il l'insee n'est pas
techniquement en mesure de rendre
possible cette vérification qui vise à
limiter le fait qu'une même personne ne
détienne de trop nombreuses procurations
faute d'outil un tel dispositif pourrait
favoriser des démarches frauduleuses et
ce n'est pas ce que nous recherchons il
me semble c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs le décret d'application de la
loi engagements et responsabilités n'a
sur ce point pas encore été pris et
c'est bien cette raison technique qui
l'en empêche
enfin votre proposition de loi comprend
des mesures utiles et le gouvernement
les partage mais encore une fois pardon
d'insister de souligner le fait qu'elle
ne relève pas du domaine de la
aussi sont elles susceptibles d'être
mises en oeuvre et je le redis comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure par décret voire
même par simple circulaire et c'est bien
notre intention que de les mettre en
oeuvre par décret ou par circulaire il
en va ainsi de l'établissement de
procuration pour les personnes
vulnérables comme je voulais déjà
indiqué mais aussi de la suppression du
motif justifiant le recours à la
procuration
il en va de même sur le matériel mis à
disposition des électeurs pour assurer
leur la prod leur protection lors du
vote
le ministre de l'intérieur s'y est déjà
engagée
non seulement nous retiendrons toutes
les préconisations du conseil
scientifique mais encore l'état prendra
à sa charge l'équipement par les
communes de ses bureaux de vote partout
où ce sera nécessaire
enfin bien évidemment la police des
bureaux de vote relève des présidents de
ces bureaux et un certain nombre de
mesures qui figurent dans le texte même
de cette proposition de loi de la
proposition de loi dont nous allons
discuter aujourd'hui relève de ce
pouvoir de police entre guillemets
d'organisation du président du bureau de
vote
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
partageons le gouvernement partage une
volonté celle que chacun puisse exprimer
son vote le 28 juin malgré le contexte
sanitaire en facilitant notamment le
recours au vote par procuration
le gouvernement partage cette ambition
il la soutient cependant le gouvernement
ne peut soutenir la proposition de loi
examiné ce jour qui abrite trop de
nombreuses mesures ne présentant pas de
caractère législatif et qui surtout
pourrait ne pas être en vigueur un terme
rapprocher les privant finalement défait
utile et notamment celle des
dispositions intéressantes et que nous
souhaitons retenir qui sont contenus
dans cette proposition de loi et qui
auront une traduction réglementaire ou
encore une fois par circulaire monsieur
le sénateur perrin vous avez cité
jacques coeur à coeur vaillant rien
d'impossible
vous savez vous parlez aussi à un
berruyer donc à coeur vaillant rien
d'impossible c'est la devise de la ville
de bourges
donc soyez certain monsieur le sénateur
que le gouvernement est attaché à mettre
beaucoup de vaillance et de
détermination à faire en sorte que la
participation soit la plus large
possible 28 juin notamment au travers
des mesures que nous prendrons
et qu'y figureront comme le veut notre
constitution dans le cadre de règlements
et parfois même de circulaire voilà
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices ce que je souhaitais vous
indiquait le sionisme et chers collègues
dont convient d'aborder par le vote par
procuration la question de du civisme
nos concitoyens et bien moi je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent que quand on
est dans des périodes exceptionnelles
il faut proposer le maximum de
dispositif pour permettre à nos
concitoyens de toutes conditions et de
tous âges pour autant qu'il soit en âge
de voter de pouvoir tenir et effectuer
utiliser le droit de vote
chacun a eu l'occasion de dire à la fois
dans la déclaration de politique
générale ou au travers d'amendements
la préoccupation pour pas dire la
surprise qu'a été le faible taux de
participation plus particulièrement
d'ailleurs dans les villes au premier
tour ça n'est pas un hasard monsieur le
premier ministre si c'est dans ces
territoires aujourd'hui qui représente
la grande majorité des français qui
n'ont pas encore choisi leur exécutif
municipal
permettez moi de vous dire que je suis
attaché à ce que le scrutin soit à la
fois avec toutes les règles de sécurité
mais aussi de sincérité et ses raisons
pour laquelle on propose à travers cet
amendement de mettre en place un vote
par correspondance qui a un avantage sur
beaucoup d'autres c'est qu'il garantit
la sécurité sanitaire dans un contexte
dont je rappelle qu'on est en état
d'urgence sanitaire
normalement jusqu'au 10 juillet je crois
qu'il faut entendre cette demande qui
monte de tous les territoires qui
commence également être largement
partagé il y à une faisabilité 7
on vous détaille je dirais le côté
opérationnel de la chose
je crois en tous les cas que le
gouvernement doit entendre cette demande
et je souhaite qu'il ne la balaie pas
d'un revers de manche ou derrière
quelques arguties qui objectivement ne
tiennent pas nous devons être à la
hauteur de l'engagement civique et du
vote de tous les français sur ces
élections de proximité et je terminerai
en disant qu'on doit aussi prendre garde
de ne pas donner le sentiment à nos
concitoyens que les élus choisirait
entre eux une espèce de cuisine
électorale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
suffisamment grave est importante pour
qu'on soit au contre au contraire au
rendez-vous de la responsabilité
c'est ce à quoi je nous appelle c'est ce
à quoi en tout les cas on propose que le
gouvernement entende et donne une suite
si chers collègues le vin rectifié bliss
est identique à celui qui vient d'être
défendue et si vous voulez bien
mais ce que je pouvais aussi défendre le
20 et le 22 l'ecti fier oui monsieur le
président je vais m'employer à les faire
à la chaîne comme vomi incité le premier
le 21 ans qui fait bis qui est identique
à celui de monsieur retailleau c'était
simplement pour dire que en ce qui nous
concerne nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire de mettre en place à votre
postale pour ceux de mes collègues qui
ont signé cet amendement pour ces
élections du 28 juin
pourquoi parce que à circonstance
exceptionnelle réponse exceptionnelle et
c'est tout simplement dans ce principe
que l'on s'inscrit pourra développer les
effets de ce vote
éventuellement ultérieurement mais ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
produire des solutions qui puissent
permettre à l'ensemble citoyens de
s'exprimer quand bien même il serait
inquiet au niveau de leur santé
parce que si c'est ce qui c'est passé
pour le premier tour
et la perspective d'une abstention aussi
forte alors que des moyens de réponse
technique pour le vote existe nous
semble regrettable et on doit inciter à
à trouver des solutions comme les
procurations comme le vote postal
d'où notre volonté de marquer j'allais
dire notre accord avec l'initiative qui
a été prise par les dépositaires de
l'amendement 19 rectifié bis alors la
vraie la vraie différence
elle se situe par rapport à nos
amendements ultérieurs dans le fait que
le dispositif proposé par l'article 10
par l'amendement 19 rectifié bis est
complet et que nous souhaitions dans
l'article va rectifier tout simplement
que eh bien on est éventuellement une
autre une autre solution
cette solution c'est tout simplement le
fait qu' on aurait un décret pris en
conseil d'état il ce décret pris en
conseil d'état nous semblait plus à
donner plus de garanties j'allais dire
sur la complétude des dispositions même
s'il est vrai que l'amendement
l'amendement précédent al'avantage de
de la vitesse quant aux derniers
amendements c'est plutôt une réflexion à
une réflexion qui l'appelle c'est de
nous dire que nous avons tous été
collectivement en matière d'opérations
démocratique pris un petit peu par la
situation et qu' il y a aucune
disposition qui dans le code électoral
nous permet de traiter ce genre de cas
qui peut être personne ne le souhaite
ici mais qui peut être est amené à se
reproduire et qu'il faudrait donc
étendre les possibilités d'un vote par
correspondance à tous les cas d'état
d'urgence sanitaire même si tous
ensemble nous souhaitons que ce genre de
deux configurations de soin de ceux ne
se renouvelle pas voilà merci chers
connaît quel est l'avis de la commission
je m'exprime sur les quatre amendements
monsieur le président en fait de
commission est favorable aux amendements
numéro 19 rectifier et 21 et qui fier
bis jusqu'en 1975 le vote par
correspondance qui était permis n'était
pas assez encadré ce qui avait donné
lieu à de graves dérives
tout le monde en est conscient c'est la
raison pour laquelle le dispositif qui
est ici proposée est un dispositif qui
perd ses cures is et si nous le mettons
en oeuvre pour les élections du 28 juin
on a une petite chance de réacclimater
une procédure qui présente pour
l'électeur davantage de de donner son
choix à personne et d'avoir l'équivalent
de l'isoloir pour exprimer secrètement
son choix c'est donc une un dispositif
qui mérite tout de même qu'on le
considère alors quelles garanties
oui parce que s'il s'agissait de
rétablir le texte d'avant 1975 on aurait
les mêmes effets il n'en est pas
question
il faut de la rigueur et nous avons
prévu dans ces deux amendements jeudi
nous parce que la commission
des lois leur a donné un avis favorable
cinq garanties la première le matériel
de vote par correspondance
il est adressé aux électeurs au plus
tard le deuxième mercredi qui précèdent
le scrutin il va falloir aller vite et
il comporte trois enveloppes une
enveloppe d'expédition une enveloppe
d'identification une enveloppe
électorale et pour permettre le contrôle
de son identité
l'électeur signe l'enveloppent
d'identification elie insère une copie
d'une pièce d'identité ainsi qu'un
justificatif de domicile
son pli et transmis au tribunal du
disquaire pas à la mairie il est
transmis au tribunal judiciaire soit par
voie postale soit par le gendarme ou le
policier assermenté troisième garantie
dans la tente du scrutin les plis sont
conservés dans un lieu sécurisé du
tribunal d'instance le greffier en chef
tient un registre du vote par
correspondance un numéro d'ordre est
apposée sur chaque pli et tout électeur
tout candidat ou son représentant peut
consulter le registre le jour du scrutin
les plis sont acheminés jusqu'aux
bureaux de vote pas requis par le
gendarme ou par le policier des agents
assermentés ceux qui peuvent d'ailleurs
établir les procurations et 4e garantie
à la clôture du bureau de vote le
président ses assesseurs a dit le numéro
du pli sur la liste d'émargement
introduisent une enveloppe contenant le
bulletin de vote dans l'urne
après s'être assuré que des lecteurs
concerné n'a pas déjà voté et comme il y
a aussi une liste au tribunal on peut
vérifier qu'il s'agit bien de la même
personne
5e garantie celle là c'est la sanction
elle est très sévère deux ans de prison
15000 euros d'amendé pour celui qui
fraude
je crois que là nous avons de quoi dire
que nous faisons un pas dans la
direction du vote par correspondance
mais nous ne le faisons qu'avec les plus
extrême précaution
ça c'est notre devoir vigilance
vis-à-vis de la sincérité de
l'expression du suffrage universel
alors puisque nous sommes favorables à
ces deux amendements identiques monsieur
le président par voie de conséquence
nous sommes défavorables aux deux autres
c'est monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs donc le
président bah a rappelé je n'y reviens
pas précédents votes par correspondance
sa suppression en 1975 pour des raisons
qu'ils étaient liés aux fraudes qu'il
était que cette mode ce vote par
correspondance était susceptible de
générer que vous avez rappelé monsieur
le président donc risque de fraude
notamment au titre du contrôle du
caractère personnel et secret du vote
il y avait sans doute des difficultés
dans l'acheminement également des
bulletins mais énormément de difficultés
qui ont fait qu'en 1975 le ce vote par
correspondance a été a été supprimé
aujourd'hui dans des délais aussi
contraint et à ce stade il n'est pas
envisageable de rétablir un vote par
correspondance pour le scrutin du 28
juin prochain qui était qui est très
rapprochées maintenant notamment eu
égard d'ailleurs délai de vote de cette
proposition loi mais pas seulement de
tout texte législatif le délai de mise
en place de la logistique qu'impose le
vote par correspondance et notamment
l'acheminement des enveloppes dont j'ai
noté donc qui transitaient par le trait
par le tribunal d'instance fin par un
tribunal pour un acheminement en mairie
par les forces de sécurité intérieure le
jour du vote il nous semble que sans
balayer d'un revers de manche comme vous
le disiez monsieur le sénateur le
principe même du vote par correspondance
il nous semble que la faisabilité
juridique et technique de la mise en
place du vote par correspondance à ce
stade paraît très délicate à mettre en
oeuvre
encore une fois il s'agit pas d'en
écarter définitivement le principe bien
au contraire vous avez posé sur la table
monsieur le président bas 5
garantie mais il semble pour résumer mon
propos ça suscitera beaucoup d'un
tendance à mettre en oeuvre dans un
délai qui est extrêmement rapprochés
donc on a des difficultés d'ordre
pratique beaucoup plus complexe que le
fait de faciliter comme cela sera mis en
oeuvre
l'obtention de procurations notamment
par le relèvement du plafond et autres
dispositions qui seront adoptées par la
voie réglementaire dont j'ai parlé
deuxièmement il faudra que nous soyons
certains dans le cadre du vote par
correspondance donc de la nécessité de
la sécurité des opérations et par
ailleurs nous sommes contraints par des
délais extrêmement courts qu'ils font
monsieur le président donc mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président cas ce qu'à ce stade et au vu
des contraintes du calendrier calendrier
électoral le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable donc au vote par
correspondance et donc émis et mais
pardon un avis défavorable à l'ensemble
de ces amendements merci monsieur le
ministre le seul aux comptes pour
explication de vote
si monsieur le président monsieur
messieurs chers collègues j'ai exprimé
tout à l'heure dans la discussion
générale mes réserves sur la
modification du droit électoral et en
particulier sur cet aspect là entre les
deux tours du même scrutin pour des
raisons de stabilité du droit électoral
et donc je n'y reviendrai pas maintenant
mais il y en plus si vous voulez
l'expérience un peu qu'on peut avoir en
la matière parce que effectivement je
comprends la préoccupation au liée à la
participation
mais je dois dire que ce type de vote
par correspondance
il existe encore en france pour les
députés des français de l'étranger
mais en réalité il est quasiment
inopérant parce que la plupart
lorsqu'ils veulent voter à distance vote
par internet
parce que dans notre procédure de vote
avec des buts a imprimé par les
candidats et non pas imprimé par
finalement la commission centrale
l'administration comme
font la plupart des pays démocratiques
il est très difficile d'organiser un
vote par correspondance en assurant sa
sûreté et donc en fait on est obligé
d'aller dans un système et c'est
finalement ce qui est proposé qui va
être très difficile à mettre en place et
qui vainquit qui n'apportera que que
très peu de choses mais même quand on
met en place le ce type de vote
avec des années d' avance comme ça se
fait pour les circonscriptions des
français de l'étranger pour les
élections législatives
ça ne marche pas alors à quelques
semaines du scrutin
franchement mieux vaut rester sur le
principe de la stabilité du droit comme
principe important du droit électoral
plutôt que d'essayer de faire quelque
chose qui de toute façon ne pourra pas
marcher parce que nous n'avons même pas
le temps de le mettre en place
correctement
merci cher collègue monsieur kerrouche
restauration des votes vous y renoncer
en fait vous êtes inscrit à vin bien
alors sur ce point qui est un point
délicat premières observations
mathieu ministre quand on veut pas
avancer manifestement on avance on
avance pas et je constate que le
gouvernement nous avait faire des
efforts énormes et surmonté beaucoup de
difficultés nous avons consenti à de
multiples dérogations mais il semblerait
que ça soit à sens unique
c'est ce que je comprends de votre
attitude par rapport au vote postal
maintenant sur celui ci en tant que tel
je pense qu'il faut quand même prendre
l'ensemble des des arguments nous ne
sommes plus en 1975 à bas n'est plus en
tête des hit parades
ça fait très longtemps les dispositions
de l'époque n'était absolument pas
sécurisé et puis il faut se rendre
compte surtout de ce qui se passe
ailleurs
ce qui se passe ailleurs c'est tout
simplement le fait que cette disposition
de vote par correspondance est largement
éprouvée et robuste dans de nombreuses
démocraties occidentales
c'est le cas de l'australie et de la
nouvelle-zélande ces cas de certains
états américains et que on aura du mal à
imaginer que eh bien nous sommes
incapables de mettre en place des
dispositifs qui ailleurs ont montré leur
pertinence et qui m'aime
vous le savez très bien ont été mis dans
l'urgence en place par don dans
l'urgence en allemagne
donc je pense que ces sondes et des
mauvais arguments sur le fond il ya un
corpus sur le vote postal qui est assez
important et qui permet de retrouver
quand même des j'avais dire des
indications substantielles sur les
qualités de ce vote d'abord on est il
est tout à fait possible de le sécuriser
des enquêtes électorales successives
menées dans l'état du colorado de
l'ontario dans l'état de washington ont
montré que le
taux de fraude au vote postal n'est pas
plus important que d'autres modalités de
vote
ça c'est le premier aspect bien entendu
il faut sécuriser deuxième aspect ce
vote est tout autre du point de vue
politique c'est à dire qu'il a été
prouvé que ils ne bénéficient pas plus à
une formation qu'à une autre
ça c'est le deuxième point est le
troisième point le plus intéressant
c'est que de voir que le vote par
correspondance a une faculté c'est que
en général
il accroît la participation
contrairement à tout ce qu'on pourrait
penser
et s'il accroît la participation et si
nous voulons faire en sorte que le
scrutin du 28 juin soit un scrutin où il
y ait le plus de participation possible
il nous semblait que c'était une
solution je pense pas que vous n'étiez
pas au courant de ces dispositifs et ce
qui est regrettable c'est qu'à force de
refuser bien entendu vous mettez à la
situation où effectivement on ne pourra
pas et si le mettre en oeuvre
merci chers collègues monsieur président
d'img abouti respiration de vote
oui sur le vote par correspondance comme
sur des facilités pour voter par
procuration un mois même les membres de
mon groupe et une sensibilité politique
je représente on y est effectivement
très favorable ensuite la mise en oeuvre
à court terme pose quand même un certain
nombre de deux difficultés qu'elles ne
posaient probablement pas en 1975 quand
on dit que les documents doivent être
adressées au plus tard le deuxième
mercredi précédent c'est la date
d'expédition sepa date de réception et
là nous sommes au 17 juin
si j'ai bien fait les calculs
ce qui veut dire que au niveau de
l'expédition aujourd'hui s'il faut
savoir c'est qui reste de grandes
méthodes soit par les services des
communes qui font appel à du personnel
municipal voire à des vacataires dans
les conditions actuelles c'est une une
utilisation qui est problématique parce
que je suppose une certaine pause mix
promiscuité disons dans l'organisation
et puis dans les grandes villes d'art et
plupart des grandes villes sondées
société de routage qui prennent ça en
charge sur des délais très courts et je
ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont pu participer
aux élections électorales ces dernières
années les dates limites de dépôt qui
sont fixés par le ministère l'intérieur
en accord avec les routeurs et je pense
en particulier des ou du routeur
parisien du grand auteur parisien
vous aviez les dates de dépôt qui
n'étaient pas les mêmes pour tous les
départements parisien pour quelle raison
parce que le nom le nombre relativement
limité de routeurs capable d'absorber
ces volume est très faible et il ne peut
pas le faire sur une journée donc c'est
pour ça que pour le premier tour des
élections municipales nous avions des
dates limites de dépôt au 28 février
et vous aviez des dates limites de dépôt
pour d'autres villes qui étaient au 5
mars
ce qui peut paraître curieux mais qui
est la réalité aujourd'hui en termes de
en terme de logistique regrouper ses
expéditions sur sur deux jours
compte tenu de l'organisation qui est
celle de l'état qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment quasiment
impossible ce qui voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait dans certains départements
fournir les imprimés puisque sa part les
bureaux de délais et professions de foi
les bulletins de vote et le matériel de
vote par correspondance partirait en
même temps il faudrait fournir un
imprimé autour du autour du 11 juin
c'est à dire dans huit jours dont
consoeur me semble-t-il un problème
logistique
ce qui n'empêche pas que il faut
réfléchir à ce qui a été dit ce qui
était dit par le président bah oui
monsieur qui rougeoie sur le principe
tout à fait d'accord mais sur le plan
logistique
un véritable problème qui est lié à
notre organisation qui est lié aussi à
la concentration d'un profession de
routeurs et à la limitation de
l'utilisation des moyens locaux pour
envoyer alors pour les petites villes de
9 pays d'habitants ou pas de problème ou
5000 habitants mais pour les grandes
concentrations urbaines ya un vrai
problème logistique
merci chers collègues messieurs pas cher
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président à porter
mes chers collègues après le vote des
ides de mars vous nous proposez le vote
par correspondance aux calendes grecques
c'est à dire c'est calandre qui n'existe
pas voilà ce que vous nous proposez
parce que vous avez fait preuve d'un
père ici sur ce vote
depuis le début souvenez vous le 4 mars
ici même j'interrogeais le gouvernement
vous m'avez répondu monsieur le ministre
sur le report des élections municipales
et du premier tour il y avait aucun
problème
le samedi soir le premier ministre
samedi soir expliquait que vous pouvez
aller voter mais on ne pouvait pas aller
et venir manger ici ou là et 24 heures
après c'était le confinement général à
l'époque vous avez eue je suppose sur un
coup de colère
une erreur de jeunesse m'aviez répondu
que j'étais indigné indigne souvenez
vous ce n'est pas grave mais ce qui est
important c'est que le sénat dans ce
texte présenté par notre collègue perrin
et amendée par le groupe centriste et le
groupe ait l'air c'est lui qui vous
proposait de remettre à plat la
démocratie et de remettre de la
participation
eh bien vous n'en avez pas tenu compte
vous avez préféré prendre un texte de
loi comme l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
dans son propos liminaire le président
bah vous avez préféré parler de texte
pour éventuellement repousser des
élections alors que dans le même temps
vous décidiez dans le même temps
vous décidiez de tenir des élections le
28 juin vous n'avez pas tenu
vous aviez trois mois pour envisager les
choses
le premier texte d'urgence vous invitais
monsieur le ministre invité le
gouvernement à prendre des dispositions
particulières
il ya des ordonnances et on a pu le
faire pour l'installation des conseils
municipaux
les quelques trente mille passer le
nombre conseils municipaux qui ont été
élus il y avait là des possibilités il y
avait là des ouvertures vous ne les avez
n'ai pas pris le temps de le faire et
donc là vous nous dites et vous avez
sans doute raison qu'on n'a plus le
temps
mais c'est vous qui l'avez pris le temps
c'est du temps perdu
c'est du temps perdu par démocratie
merci cher collègue monsieur savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mais mes chers collègues je
l'avais dit au tout début du point de
vue du comportement de notre groupe on
s'acheminerait jusqu'à au vote a au
final en fonction des débats que nous
avons ici là franchement avec ses
propositions de vote par voie postale on
est bien au-delà des contraintes du coc
vie de dix neuf puisque c'est des
projets qui étaient déjà déjà qui
existait avant certains ont fait
référence ici à des expérimentations
dans un certain nombre de pays où je
suis pas sûr que tous les pays qui ont
été cités sont des modèles de démocratie
et deuxièmement dans ces pays là ils
n'ont pas le même maillage territorial
que la france faut aussi qu'on prenne
pas en compte c'est que là on parle de
plus de 30 mille communes tout le monde
n'a pas ce maillage de proximité du
point de vue d'aider des autres sociétés
mais voilà les un petit sujet c'est
comment modifier structurellement le
rapport au vote
entre deux tours d'élections ça pose
question
ça peut examiner ça peut se discuter
mais ça se prépare ça demande un débat
n'est pas clos est aussi honnête avec de
l'humidité ça demande un débat que nos
concitoyens
ça demande des conditions de garantie
moi je dis pas qu'elles sont pas
tenables mai
réunis on peut pas comparer on peut pas
prendre de risque de ce point de vue là
donc franchement mais des communes
il ya des communes où le maire il aurait
été élu par le mode de scrutin
traditionnel puis y en a qui vont être
élus par correspondance
il y en a d'autres non non non
franchement on a je vous dis ça moi je
vais pas chercher plus malveillant je ne
sais quoi là dedans il ya un problème
d'unité républicaine dans le rapport à
l'acte électoral
donc s'il ya des changements à faire
pour aller faire à d'autres élections on
examinera de manière apaisée responsable
en n'ayant pas peur de comparaison avec
d'autres démocraties mais on regardera
aussi on posera aussi la question à à
nos concitoyens
moi je me sens nous sommes interrogés le
groupe 1 est ce que ce cet amendement
est gagé ici ça nous arrive souvent
d'avoir des bonnes idées puis des fois
ici on se retrouve avec quoi comme
argument hop
l'idée peut-être pas mauvais mais
hartigan on peut pas donc moi je pose la
question ici et là j'en doute pas c'est
quand même la majorité du sénat
falla qui élargissent sur ce sujet vous
avez dû penser à ce que cette
proposition soit gagée financièrement
moi je ne sais pas je vous dis
franchement on parle de plusieurs
millions je me méfie des rumeurs
voyaient des surenchères aussi 60 80
millions etc etc
bon voilà je demande si mon nom de se
dégager et je termine mes propos mes
chers collègues peut-être à ma façon
mais quand le 22 juin va pouvoir aller
au cinéma super on va pouvoir aller au
théâtre
super on va pouvoir aller au restaurant
super on pourra pas aller voter on
pourra pas aller voter
merci cher collègue madame mercier ou
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
la situation est inédite en plus il faut
organiser des élections lors d'un état
d'urgence sanitaire
mais je crois que la proposition qui est
faite elle est raisonnable
j'en veux pour preuve l'élection que
nous faisons nous lors de du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins il faut
élire les représentants
eh bien nous votons par correspondance
on prend le but
on le met dans la petite enveloppe bleue
la petite enveloppe bleue dans
l'enveloppé orange on signe et on en
voit ce qu'on veut en fait c'est ramener
les électeurs nous voulons combattre
l'abstention
nous voulons favoriser le vote et nous
voulons juste fortifier la démocratie et
je crois que quand vraiment on veut ça
eh bien on sait s'en donner les moyens
merci chers collègues je vais mettre aux
voix
tout d'abord les deux amendements
identiques 19 rectifié bis et 21
rectifié bis avis favorable de la
commission est défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés le sénat
a donc adopté cette proposition de loi
qui facilite le vote lors du scrutin du
second tour des élections municipales 28
juin prochain les sénateurs ont autorisé
le vote par correspondance
un vote pourtant interdite depuis 1975
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous
d'information politique et parlementaire
notre émission spéciale questions
d'actualité à 14h50 présentés par thèmes
tran huy je vous souhaite une très bonne
journée sur public sénat
[Musique]